[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
well okay them now but definitely I
would definitely drink eggnog yeah hell
yeah I don't know I'm not really into it
you know I know I don't understand it
well it's like drinking melted ice cream
yeah yeah it's [ __ ] real fasting you
know
it's like I I don't I don't mind it like
in a little like a little thing but it's
like I can't drink a whole big glass of
it it's kind of sickly you know what I
mean well I put a lot of ice in it let
the ice melt water it down so it water's
down yeah I guess I don't I don't drink
it it's thick yeah I know it's a little
too thick if you ask me I like it to
kind of thin down a little bit I think I
kind of weird me out like I like
milkshakes I'm not saying that but I
don't know there's something I'm not
kind of I bet if you put ice in there
and then hit it with the immersion
blender and turn it into a smoothie it's
probably really good
yeah probably yeah I don't know I don't
know why I'm because I you would think
that I would like that but
because I like milkshakes and I like
Frappuccinos like that and I like ice
cream yeah but for some reason it's not
that I don't like it it's just I don't
know there's something kind of sickly
about it like I said it's thick yeah a
lot of people have a hard time getting
over that it's just real thick and sweet
Rich yeah maybe if I drank it through a
straw yeah
[Laughter]
like I say if it's iced and it's
slightly and the ice melts and it
slightly Waters down a lot of people
like it better like that I like it like
that with a little a little slightly
watered down yeah I guess see what
they're talking about and I'm kind of
one of those people that likes milk with
ice in it too well I like everything has
to have ice in it because I'm in Florida
man and I'm not sure I don't I don't
play that like we're drinking some
[ __ ] room temperature [ __ ] no thanks
yeah yesterday was funny because
we had somebody an account jump in the
comments section uh name uh Jen Draven
and we started talking about her like
it's our friend Jen because that's right
talk to her said thanks for stopping in
she said I didn't show up there that
wasn't that wasn't our gen Draven I
don't know who that was
it's a mystery we yeah I know we were
talking to her last night like on
messenger and she's like that was at me
yeah she goes tell me if you tell me
tell me when you start streaming I'll
jump in say hi so she might jump in okay
but now I'm like wondering who the [ __ ]
that was yeah they were like who the
[ __ ] is using my name you know
but you know anybody can do anything I
think you can change your name in the
chats in in the chat but the fact that
somebody would come on here and like use
that name specifically means it's
probably somebody that knows us yeah or
knows her yeah
sorry or just uh I mean unless it was
like a really really bizarre coincidence
but I kind of doubt it I kind of doubt
it yeah we're chip that is very we only
said one thing so that was it yeah well
it's like I didn't really think anything
of it because like I said Dimitri shows
up sometimes yeah and that's you know
yeah and what she said sounded like
something Jen would say
yeah that's what I mean so I was just
kind of like I don't know it was just
very bizarre it was very bizarre when we
found out that wasn't her because then I
was like ooh now I'm like intrigued I'm
wondering if that's like some stalker or
something yeah
she just jumped it said I was getting
jacked and Jen says that all the time
when she sees me you're getting big
yeah yeah so that's why we didn't it's
not like yeah it's not like they came on
and because that's like all she said
yeah yeah so it's not like they just
came on or were like [ __ ] with us or
something like that so funny that's why
I didn't really have any cause to doubt
that it was actually her but she said
that it wasn't yeah
granther said you were suspicious of old
grandther too once Yeah well yeah you
didn't tell me who you were man
yeah that's kind of that's the thing
that's the thing yeah you didn't tell me
who you were we're not really sure yeah
we can't see we can't see y'all yeah
we can't see y'all
yeah Tammy said you should tell her to
say something in the chat that only the
three of you would know
she has her own account so when she
comes into the chat it would lead back
to her account
she has her own YouTube account
and it's not under that name it is under
John Draven but it has uh next to her
face as an icon with her picture oh okay
and if you you when you press that in
this in this thing you can go back and
see where that see that person's home
page so it would lead back to hers okay
well I can't do it from here like I
can't click on the one that was talking
there was no photograph it was just a
purple disc with j in it
like a generic one right yeah yeah
I didn't check it though I just you know
just I didn't either because like I said
it's not like they came on or like you
know spewing abuse at us or something
like that it was just it was just
something that she probably normally
would have said so it's not really that
weird
John Smith said he's making mulled wine
over Christmas
Christmas day is the only day you can
have chocolate cake for breakfast and be
drunk by 10 o'clock and it's not a grave
cause for concern
I got I got Christmas dinner already
half done because guess what I did
what'd you do I'd say I saved all the
damn stuffing the dressing yeah
Thanksgiving it's frozen hey you're
Frozen yeah we didn't even scratch the
surface well I mean you made a lot made
stuffing yeah and I love stuffing and
everything but even I can't eat that
much I put it in a Ziploc bag of frozen
I said we're having this for Christmas
okay so I'm gonna cook that turkey
without any stuffing in it I'm just
gonna keep basting it and then you know
we're gonna eat that that stuff again
like that okay I'll make cranberry sauce
though okay I'll make that I got
cranberries are you gonna make real
potatoes or just instant ones I can make
real ones I think yeah because we had
instant ones for Thanksgiving yeah it's
like a little bit I don't think I have
any real potatoes in there I have to
check oh well I have sweet potatoes real
sweet potatoes yeah all right
although I probably want to make
something like sweet potato pie with
that well yeah that's what I mean you
can do other stuff with that you can do
other stuff with me pumpkin pie yeah
that pumpkin pie that pumpkin pie you
made is good I'll make another one okay
and then um
yeah
I wasn't on so much gear I'd be getting
fat
well it's the holidays you know
everybody's yeah everybody's entitled to
get a little fat over the holidays it's
kind of like
that's just kind of what you do you know
yeah
so today this is this this show here man
is gonna be a [ __ ]
um real inspiring show
[Laughter]
[ __ ] put you all in a good mood this
is [ __ ] Halloween tragedies all the
[ __ ] Christmas Christmas excuse me
Christmas tragedies this Halloween
Christmas same [ __ ] for us anyway it's
just Gothic Christmas Halloween is
gothic Christmas but uh we're gonna
this one's gonna uh
be real upbeat
well you know
I kind of feel like it always happens
other than maybe our first Christmas
special many years ago when we did kind
of a fun one that was like Christmas
creatures or something like that yeah
like other than that I'm always just
kind of like well upbeat Christmas [ __ ]
it's kind of like boring so
yeah you know it's it's always more fun
to do I don't know it's I don't know if
it's more fun necessarily but like I
said it might in in some ways it makes
me feel better because I'm like well at
least my Christmas isn't as shitty as
these peoples you know what I mean yeah
the um so that's one way to look at it
what was I gonna say about that oh [ __ ]
last night we were watching
Unsolved Mysteries they had two we
watched two of them they were good yeah
it looks like they put a new season up
on Netflix because I didn't I mean
unless I missed it because I didn't I
don't remember those yeah I don't
remember but I know I didn't see the UFO
one they had it they have a new UFO one
that's real good that happened like in
the 90s and it's called Uh
something in the sky
and it's got some radar operators
there's people that saw some cops that
saw something it's kind of reminded me
of that old Illinois triangle UFO
triangle over Illinois
answered it it's one of my favorite ones
the cops even got a picture of it uh
with the Polaroid camera and they were
the whole I think two or three different
police departments over two states saw
this damn triangle you know the flying
low
this one's just lights
disconnected and breaking apart they
didn't actually one person said she saw
it it was just silver a silvery craft
she said cylindrical
they showed a disc but she said
cylindrical
they're always funny how those programs
do that you know what I mean the witness
says one thing but then what they show
you is is totally different
I don't really like that yeah well it's
like either she didn't know what a
cylinder was or the person doing the 3D
art didn't know what a cylinder was
maybe she didn't know what a cylinder
was maybe she meant disc
but uh that's a good UFO one Jenny hates
UFO stuff she falls asleep Darren I
don't hate it it's just a lot of it's
kind of Stamey
still I like it well I fell asleep
because I was tired now the first one
that we watched which was like a real
bummer but I was like riveted through
that one that was the one about the girl
that um that was in 94 95 something like
that that girl that um got hit by the
train
yeah and for a long time they said that
it was like suicide but they were like
yeah no [ __ ] way that she probably
got murdered and like laid on the track
yeah but they didn't like him they found
your stuff in another location somebody
killed her
yeah put her on a track
yeah this is [ __ ] up yeah that was
[ __ ] up
um but there's some good [ __ ] that's
there's some good [ __ ] on there we have
to watch the rest of that like later
yeah I think that was that I think it
was uh the new Unsolved Mysteries I
think it was season three
yeah it's season three yeah and it's
season three episode two is something in
the sky I think it's just called lights
in the sky or no some there's something
in the sky I think something something
in the sky
[Laughter]
the radar was backing it up the radar
operator was seeing a thing over Lake
Michigan
hiding out in the in the place where the
lake wasn't Frozen and he watched it for
out there for hours and it said it would
just be there to break apart into four
or five of them and then he'd come back
and it swarmed said they were doing
patterns in the sky
and there was a a witness on the ground
at that same time
that said that they that she said she
saw it
and it was uh about six thousand feet
off the ground pulling water up out of
the lake in like a reverse waterfall
pulling it up into okay
that part happened and it was doing that
for about an hour just pulling this
mysterious [ __ ] and it was kind of
wavering like it was in a tractor beam
and it was pulling it up into the craft
and you know the craft what she didn't
describe as being very big so I I don't
know what it was doing
they couldn't have been pulling that
much water but you could see it
and she didn't say anything was coming
back down maybe they're bigger on the
inside than they are on the outside
like a tardis like a tardis
pulling water in there you know you
needed water fresh water I guess
it says some of yours yes
John Smith said well that guy that
incinerated his in-laws with a homemade
flamethrower while dressed as Santa was
pretty tragic too
I didn't see that one wait was that like
was that a real story because I feel
like we talked about because we did I
think it was last year the year before
we did uh horrible murders that happened
on Christmas
and uh so this year I was doing
tragedies although I will say that there
is one in here that was murders that I
somehow missed like on that show so
we're gonna talk about that Graveler
says uh grandfather's present to his
wife is getting a vasectomy so she
doesn't have to be on birth control
anymore
how's that for a Christmas gift that's
actually I made you laugh but I mean
that seems like that's a very thoughtful
gift actually that's very very nice of
you
uh and then John Smith said nothing is
more tragic at Christmas than Phoebe
Kate's story about her father and
Gremlins yeah that's um that's a real
bummer and you know what's like a bummer
about that too is that that's happened
to people in real life not dressed as
Santa I don't think but didn't that
happen to that kid where he got stuck in
the chimney
like trying to break into the house or
some [ __ ] yeah he died in there yeah
that's what I'm saying yeah yeah well
yeah remember that in in Gremlins she
tells the story about her dad coming
down the chimney dress like Santa Claus
and getting stuck in there yeah yeah he
was kind of trying to break into that
house
he went down the chimney feet first
got stuck couldn't get in there
and he was missing for a couple years
you know nobody lived in that house it
was owned but nobody lived in it
somebody tried to use that that uh
fireplace eventually
and uh
smoke wouldn't go on about as well there
was old rotten dude up there they found
him
mummified up in the [ __ ] yeah he's
probably like like human jerky yeah
Brody yep
I mean I'm sure it's happened more than
once
don't try to break into a house by going
down the chimney kids all he had to do
was bust a window
I mean I don't yeah I don't know like
why the [ __ ] would you I guess you
wanted to go in and out of there without
doing any damage to it so he could just
have access to the house you know
because uh he probably figured nobody
lived there it was abandoned
you know yeah I guess but it seems like
there'd be much easier ways to
accomplish that he was a teenager
they're dumb that's true
yeah
he probably thought he was being clever
as [ __ ] though yeah let's go down to
them chimney no it'll even see me yeah
chimney sweeps do it
[Laughter]
he's probably sliding down singing the
song for [ __ ] very popular chim
chimney yeah and then he's like oh [ __ ]
for some reason he I guess it could be
too tight it got too tight he couldn't
crawl up
man imagine he [ __ ] screamed in there
and yelled for help for a long time yeah
can you imagine
Jesus [ __ ] Christ take you about
seven days to die of thirst
yeah it would take a while yeah you'd
die in a way that's kind of like some
[ __ ] out of town
[ __ ] Stephen King novel
you'd go crazy in there but you nothing
you could do
yeah that that don't fall down in any
smaller don't fall into any tight areas
I'm I got claustrophobia like that I
cannot stand any kind of tight area I
got a [ __ ] paranoia about it because
you can't move
see I don't understand how those people
can go down to those [ __ ] caves that
crawl in between those cracks they're
[ __ ] crazy yeah yeah see I don't I
don't mind going down in a cave if it's
a nice big cave yeah that looks like a
pretty cool [ __ ] crack but you
started crawling these little cracks of
holes in like in The Descent no thank
you yeah they don't know where it's
going let's see where this goes it's
getting tighter let's keep going it I
was like um it goes to another cave
spoiler alert it's probably looks just
the same as the cave that you came from
yeah so
[Laughter]
I gotta say you know I'm gonna go throw
them other crazy [ __ ] into the
same [ __ ] batch and let those people
that climb up the sides of those sheer
Cliff faces
yeah yeah and then they want to call for
help when they get in trouble you know
like they ought to just make a rule if
you climb up that [ __ ] okay you're on
your own you know I mean without any
safety equipment or harnesses well they
have sometimes but still two you know
they're [ __ ] just hanging by the
[ __ ] very edges and
you know you're crazy well it is kind of
a bummer that like people like with
families and kids and job that's their
job like that they have to go and rescue
people right and like it's not like you
have to be up there doing that you're
just doing it for like Thrills and stuff
I'm like maybe more of the thrill would
be that if you [ __ ] up no one can help
you right
I thought that was like part of the
whole extreme sports kind of thing yeah
I'm not saying don't do it if that's
your thing go ahead and do it but nobody
should help you
I mean it's yeah and it's like it's
different if you know if somebody's just
like hiking and they get lost or
something like that that's you know
there's I don't have a problem with
people getting like getting rescued then
but if you're doing like some of that
extreme [ __ ] like you said you know I
don't think that those dudes will
[ __ ] drive a damn steak into the
spike into the [ __ ] wall of that cave
and hang a hammock through there and
sleep in between you know what I mean
between climbing that's that's a lot of
skill I'm gonna say that you know yeah I
respect it you got [ __ ] balls but if
you get in trouble
you're on your own I'm not going up
there to get you I wouldn't expect
anybody else to go up and get you
I mean I would think that if I was the
kind of person that did that kind of
stuff for kicks would you not shouldn't
be asking for help then I would be like
well I'm probably gonna be on my own
like if the [ __ ] happens I wouldn't
expect somebody to like risk their
Athletics account me
yeah same thing going down into the
caves no maybe other rock climbers are
into that [ __ ] well you know you got
some other crazy but we'll just go get
him you know yeah well that's fair
enough that's fair enough
yeah I'm not saying just like don't go
rescue them in a spite I'm not saying
that right
you better be some kind of rock climber
you're into that yeah like you're you
you want to go you you pop a boner on
thinking I'm gonna climb up this rock
and save this other stupid [ __ ]
that's your thing then go ahead and do
it
[ __ ] you're gonna die too
John Smith said there are some mad fools
that will climb Frozen waterfalls
yeah
I don't know it's just to me it seems
like look I understand like you know the
whole Adrenaline Rush thing and
everything like that but just doing
stuff like that just seems like why like
why
well they had that one dude who was
getting on top of the buildings and
taking selfies of himself hanging off
the side he'd get into these weird
cracks he'd go onto the end of a Down
pull and stand there he could tightrope
yeah and walk and he fell yeah well
eventually eventually that's gonna
happen wind came and got him he forgot
about wed yeah
yeah it's like you know I don't I don't
really feel bad yeah I mean never I
don't really feel yeah
you're on the 96th floor dude with
oh
bye-bye yes yeah to be honest I don't
even like thinking about being on top of
a tall building I don't even like
watching a movie of people being on top
of a tall building even if it's fake
yeah it stresses me the [ __ ] out the one
time I went to New York City and I went
up to the top of the Empire State
Building just because it's New York City
and you kind of have to it's the law but
yeah but I wanted to say that I'd been
up there and the whole time I was just I
was freaking out I was just kind of I
like I wanted to go up there but it's
like when I got to the top I was like
inching to warm the thing and then it's
like they're like look over the thing
and I was like oh I don't like it I was
like I want to go back down the crowd
and it's like you can feel it like
blowing around kinda and I was just like
and then I was like looking at other
people like sticking their heads out and
I'm just like I really have to get the
[ __ ] out of here like stress me out so
badly I'm a veteran of the 101st
Airborne Division went to aerosol school
which really wasn't [ __ ]
up and [ __ ] did a bunch of air
assault operations in the [ __ ] 506
when they were up in Korea right off at
DMZ Camp Graves and we got more flight
time than dudes from the 101st even
though 506 came from the 101st
originally we were kind of like on loan
I love flying doors open and [ __ ]
helicopters all right uh want Huey's
um
you ate 60 Blackhawks
for [ __ ] going probably like 120
knots doors open [ __ ] banking at an
angle I'd be on the [ __ ] uh during
that a lot of that during that whole
time I was a 60 Gunner so always got the
very last seat either on the right or
the left side of the fuselage towards
the back and the front of that damn
fuselage is tapered so if you look
straight ahead you're actually looking
forward because the fuselage gets so
your feet could kind of hang out over
the side you used to love it
the chopper would back he'd be all
strapped in you'd look down try to spit
because we were [ __ ] dipping spit out
they get caught in the prop wash and hit
everybody and everybody laughed and [ __ ]
you know yeah it's just the way it was
dude they're disgusting but for soon
but my first [ __ ] but still beside
all that the hardest thing I [ __ ]
ever did personally was [ __ ] climb up
top this [ __ ] ladder
the very last at the air assault School
the very last wrong you had to jump up
and it's because you have perspective
John Smith just said that he said I
don't respect I don't have any fear of
heights so it's fine for me I'd be more
unnerved being at the top of a ladder
because I can conceive of a broken egg
exactly exactly well I don't know I can
see you falling off a [ __ ] hundred
story building too I can I can conceive
that really well maybe my imagination
like it gets me in trouble real high
buildings looking over the edge it's
even it's worse for me the whole vertigo
because you have perspective that you
can fall yeah
but no problem at all jumping out of a
helicopter on a [ __ ] what is it 200
foot line the chopper repels no problem
easy
and I just because I guess because the
perspective isn't the same there isn't a
wall that goes straight down
yeah maybe that's what it is and you're
moving and you know you're flying I
think it has a lot to do with it
you're not on yeah you're not just like
standing there solid and then yeah
you're not on something you're flying
because that's like a very very
unnerving right feeling where you're
standing on top of a building and it's
not moving and you're it's your anchor
to safety well your anchor to say if
you're already flying you're not really
anchored to anything so yeah maybe
that's what it is and you don't have a
good perspective just things look small
and far away
and you don't really have a sense of up
and down because everything's kind of
doing this you know what I mean if I can
get you flying around you feel like
you're in control of it yeah so maybe
they have that feeling of being in
control as they're walking across a
tightrope between two buildings you know
well you'd have to otherwise you
wouldn't be able to do it right
yeah Zach says I think the most
uncomfortable thing I ever saw was that
Elder French dude who broke World
Records by balancing and chairs off the
edge of cliffs skyscrapers Etc is that
the same guy that they made the
documentary man on wire about because I
saw that like at a little Indie theater
and he was French and he just like would
walk well he did it like illegally he
would take like a he'd sneak in I think
he did between the World Trade Centers
too like he'd sneak in while it was
under construction and throw like a wire
between the two buildings and then he'd
walk like he didn't get permits or
nothing like that he never fell though I
mean he was like but that was a great
documentary but man I was like [ __ ]
so stressed out watching that even
though I knew that he didn't fall like I
knew he was still alive like when I saw
the documentary I was still like
thinking that he was gonna fall the
whole time Zach also said isn't it
normal to have that call of the Void
experience like you're on top of a tall
building and you feel the impulse to
jump for a second or something similar
yeah I've heard that a lot of people
have that I've had that I kind of feel
like most people have well I don't
really accents it that way I have I have
the Sensation that the floor is slightly
sloped and I'm slightly being pulled or
sliding I feel like I'm kind of sliding
towards the edge
I'm not though but I kind of have that
feeling like I'm being pulled towards
the edge yeah yeah I know what you're
saying yeah the cat it's like ver it's
some kind of vertigo
yeah I almost kind of feel like well you
almost kind of feel like unmoored for a
second like yeah
like I'm gonna lose my balance even if
I'm just standing there like I said when
I was on top of the Empire State
Building like obviously like you can't
really fall off unless you try really
hard because there's you know the walls
like this and then there's you know
rungs up there like that so you'd have
to like climb up and over but like even
then like I still felt like I could just
go and just like fall off the edge and
there's no way that I could yeah but but
just like just like he said
being at the top of that huge long
ladder made out of damn telephone poles
and aerosol school was scarier than
actually looking out of that [ __ ]
open doors or or jumping out on a line
200 200 foot live not a problem if I was
on the in that Chopper and had a shoot
on and we were Banking and and somebody
pushed me and said jump jump
I had no problem jumping I wouldn't even
hesitate like yeah and just jump out
because it doesn't seem like you don't
it doesn't seem like you're high off the
ground
you know yeah there's no perspective
you just see little trees and little
things you know
it doesn't really matter
you don't feel like you're high off the
ground just things look the ground looks
just looks far away
yeah
I guess
we've never flown have you
or have you flogged you just don't like
flying I just don't like flying I fly
lots of times yeah that's right
never in a helicopter but I've flown in
like regular planes and like little and
like little planes helicopters totally
different it's a lot like being in a
motorcycle
well I don't really like being on the
back of a motorcycle either
doors are open winds blowing through a
lot of sound
and everybody's in there
I mean I get some people really like it
but like I said to me it just seems like
courting disaster when there's really no
reason to you know what I mean like
especially people that just jump out of
planes just because like for Thrills
yeah I don't have a problem with that
you know well people can do it but it's
like I don't know it would be harder to
do base jumping for me to just jump off
run and jump off the edge of a cliff
even I've had a shoot on I'd have a hard
time doing that but yeah I have a plan I
would have it wouldn't be a problem
yeah I don't know I just I don't like
either idea to be honest
Camp guy said uh that dude that free
climbs in yosem and Yosemite is freaky I
can't even watch that [ __ ] on video yeah
I don't like any of them dudes Yeah well
yeah I can't watch I can't watch that
even if you know that they're not gonna
fall because it's like you know
obviously they they did the made the
video and somebody uploaded it so like
if if you know that they're still alive
but like I said even that documentary
about that french guy even though I knew
he was alive when I watched the
documentary I still like had a hard time
watching it I guess they just lean into
it you know they just [ __ ] like it
and I guess you have to like it but
there's I just don't like the way that
looks man I get a weird video weird
vertigo feeling seeing that
I mean [ __ ] man I have I get vertigo
kind of like I and dizzy like that just
walking up and down the [ __ ] stairs
like much less no I do I'm serious like
my well I had problems like when I was a
teenager I had problems with my inner
ear okay so a lot of times my um my
balance isn't all that good so I'm
always kind of like worried that
you know that I'm gonna trip and fall or
something like that because I always
feel like a little bit you know what I
mean like I was feeling like a little
bit wobbly so that's probably another
reason that I don't like standing on top
of really tall things
I don't even like climbing ladders I
don't even like like if I have to climb
up on the on the counter like to change
a light bulb or something like that that
[ __ ] stresses me out even though
that's only like a couple feet off the
ground I don't like that either
because I get dizzy
I can't help it like you know my inner
ears [ __ ] up I get dizzy so it like
makes me really so I'm always afraid I'm
gonna like fall and Buzz my head open
you know what I mean
Camp guy said I saw one where a dude was
hanging around asking questions at a
skydiving School the owner let him go up
to watch a jump and this guy jumped out
with all the parachute dudes it was a
suicide oh really wow okay holy [ __ ] can
you [ __ ] imagine
it freaked out the pilot or the owner
guy yeah I'm sure oh and he didn't have
a shoot on he just well yeah he just
jumped out oh man
like I guess it was suicide or he was
just stupid like we I better like he got
all caught up in it and then he was like
oh [ __ ] let's go
[Laughter]
Tom Sykes said I'm sure somewhere out in
the world there's a Christmas holiday
tragedy of some poor ladder last deep
throating a candy cane and choking to
death yeah I'm I imagine that choking on
candy canes is probably pretty common I
mean it was like not common common but I
imagine it's probably happens quite a
bit like around this time of year
they get sharp you know no telling and
like they break up and like you know
they get broken and you can [ __ ]
Camp guys to the news lady asked if you
surprised him when the guy jumped out
well [ __ ] yeah it surprised me what do
you think
what a dumb [ __ ] question all right
so um I guess we have a couple of shout
outs now a couple of these we did like
on the movie shows but like I said I
always like to do them on the main show
so I wanted to give a shout out to our
newest Patron
whose name is seven lines uh so thank
you very much for joining our little
family over on patreon uh you know and
we do have a patreon by the way if you
want to go over there and get in on that
yeah we're always looking for new
patrons man patronage has been [ __ ]
[ __ ] us up man we lost a bunch of
them over the past couple years
I'm trying to get some patrons back we
are yeah yeah and basically I mean you
get to uh vote on like sometimes what
movies we talk about or what um topics
that we're gonna do on the show and
sometimes I put up like Early Access I
haven't been doing that in the last
couple weeks because I got really sure
of behind yeah sometimes we send out
shirts yeah stuff like that which yeah
it's probably due to send shirts out
again we've been blowing shirts off
money and everything that's been
happening well yeah like I said it's
around the holidays and the last couple
months I've just been like broke as [ __ ]
so it's like I don't really uh funny
thing is is anytime shirts come around
we we send out uh emails to everybody
messages asking you know what design
what's what size you want and only like
130 you all even ever respond so y'all
don't get a shirt
you don't respond well I'm sure like
everybody here does yeah respond yeah
there's I mean there are some people on
our patreon though some people they
don't ever respond to the message so
they don't ever get the shirt which you
know you know so well I mean I mean they
still really care about you they're
trying to chip in I guess well yeah
that's what I mean it's like you know
because like I said I'm on a couple
people's patreon like I give a little
bit but you know a lot of times I don't
really take advantage of all this extra
[ __ ] they gave you because I just don't
have time to take advantage of it I just
don't yeah like I said I give Dan Bell
like a buck or two but and he has all
this like podcasts on there that are
patreon only and I was like oh that
sounds fun and I should do that one day
but I just never have time to listen to
them so
you know what I mean
Mike says Jenny you look like when you
do uh giallo reviews yeah I decided to
do my red hair because it was like
Christmassy yeah I guess I forgot I have
a green wig too yeah I don't have I
don't have a Santa hat though Jen's
better look good lately man it's almost
time for another uh photo shoot on Jen
we're gonna do it only fans photo shoot
you keep saying I'm Gonna Get You dolled
up man it's gonna be sexy
yeah okay
[Laughter]
boots and everything lots of leg
cleavage
yeah you can look like a porn star she
see look at her she's like yeah yeah but
we already did a photo shoot like that
it was a big hit
it's been a long time well yeah that was
a long time ago we got to do one for
like your 50th like
too late now I already turned 50. yeah
well we'll just say we did it then when
you're 50.
let's save it for 51. yeah
Mike says sorry Jenny I'm drunk well no
that's okay you're all right
you're all right we'll probably be drunk
by the time this is yeah I mean what I
did on this show uh was I kind of picked
out like
three sort of big ones that I wanted to
talk about and then there's like a
couple like other little ones if we have
time to like get into that because
somebody mentioned the Indian Ocean
tsunami and I said yeah I might bring
that up toward the end but I kind of
feel like more people know about that
one because it happened like more
recently so I kind of picked out some
older stuff that I didn't know that much
about that happened on Christmas and
like I said we did do
last year the year before I think we did
like horrible murders that happened on
Christmas like the Lawson family and
stuff like that so I didn't want to
repeat any of that stuff but I did find
some stuff that we hadn't talked about
previously so hopefully that'll be
exciting for us and like I said it's a
Christmas special so I'm sure we'll
probably go off topic as usual uh you
know what I mean but that's why I put in
the title like Christmas tragedies and
more I should probably start doing that
on every [ __ ] topic because we always
end up talking about all the other [ __ ]
oh well
that's the point of the show
is it well you know kinda
I don't know because it depends on who
you ask yeah
some people like it some people don't
it's like I know you can't make
everybody happy yeah um I do like the
live streams I like the spontaneity of
it yeah but
I think like I said the Sidetrack shows
are like actually a lot more fun for me
because I'm not stressing out about oh
you know we need to get back to the
topic or we need to get back to the
topic you know what I mean because we
can just like talk about with anything
um John Smith said on a Christmas theme
anyone seen the slasher don't open till
Christmas in which a mass killer is
murdering men dressed as Santa Claus
um did we did that just come out because
I was looking earlier today oh here's
another thing so I was I've been trying
to put up some more
um like Christmas horror movie reviews
this week so I watched one and I was and
I wrote the script for it and I was
gonna do like a video
and put it up today so I got the whole
thing like the whole review written and
I saved it and everything like that and
then my computer crashed and when I
restarted it the entire thing was gone
like the file was still there but all of
it was gone and I couldn't get it back
like I went into like tried to I went to
like the temporary files and I tried to
like restore and all this other kind of
stuff and it was just gone like the file
was still there like I had saved it but
all of the text was gone and I was just
kind of like oh my God I was like I
wonder why uh I just wanted to [ __ ]
scream to be honest with you I was like
oh my God I spent all that time like
doing that so now I have to do it again
tomorrow so I didn't put up a review
today and even though I meant to because
that happened
so you know I wasn't in the best frame
of mind this afternoon I'm just gonna
say it because all that [ __ ] work and
it was [ __ ] gone
Zach says uh I like the Sidetrack shows
because it's just an unending stream of
stream of Consciousness yeah
don't open till Christmas is from the
80s maybe we did review it I feel like
we did a [ __ ] ton of Christmas horror
movies last year or the year before I
don't remember and maybe that was one of
them
I want to see has anybody seen the new
one that's on shutter what the [ __ ] is
it called I might get around to watching
that one but the one I watched yesterday
that I did the review for was called red
snow but um
from 2021 and it was pretty good but now
I have to like [ __ ] redo the whole
review because I [ __ ] lost it
uh Hugo said you guys should watch
violent night Tom is gonna like it yeah
I've been wanting to see that actually
it's still at the theater I don't it's
probably um not streaming it
uh yeah 1984. the killer tracks down and
kills Salvation Army Grotto and Mall
Santas
see that sounds familiar
that sounds familiar maybe we did review
that I know I have to look back and see
because we've done so many [ __ ]
we've done so many Christmas horror
movies you know what I mean yeah all
right so um where was I oh okay so
thanking our new Patron seven lines so
thank you very much uh again somebody
sent Pookie a big box of tuna Shiba meat
sticks oh really yeah is it today no
yesterday yesterday or yesterday or the
day before yeah yeah
and every time another one no no no and
um and I don't know and I don't remember
who it was because they didn't put their
name on it but if it was you then
because I remember somebody asking about
it but I don't remember
like who was it asked about it so I
don't know who it was that sent it but
whoever was sent it like thank you very
much uh Pokey loves those like I said
they're her very very favorite
um Tom Sykes said violent night is free
on the one two three movies site oh okay
yeah I've been wanting to see that
actually because that's the one with
David Harbor right here that was in uh
stranger things and I like him he's he'd
make a good like Santa tell you know
what I mean but we'll see that one as
well there's but there's a new one on
shutter too but I can't remember what
the name of it is but it looks good and
it got like good reviews and stuff so I
might get around to watching that one
too but like I said
we'll see we'll see I wanted to do
um inside as well from 2007 because
that's not a Christmas Christmas movie
but I think it takes place on Christmas
oh Tom says all all new movies are free
on that side okay it's probably one of
those
um but yeah and the only other thing
like I said we already plugged the
patreon
um I also wanted to tell everybody if
you haven't already please go over and
subscribe to my other two channels one
of which is called the scare salon and
that's all horror stuff and the other
one is called crime immemorial and
that's all True Crime stuff so I'm
trying to like I said I'm trying to get
a thousand subscribers on each of those
so I can monetize them
but you know we're getting there but
it's very very slow
Oscar says American Psycho is
technically a Christmas movie that's
true and you know what I was thinking
the other day that I don't think we've
uh that we've done a video on American
Psycho either I don't think so no I
don't think we have
I think we put
um I put it in the poll a couple times
but it just never wins because there's
always another one that's in there
Mike says did I miss your review of dark
glasses
um yeah I did do a review of dark
glasses
probably a month or so ago something
like that it was over in the I think I
did it on the I can't remember if I did
it on scare Salon or I might have done
it on the flickers of fear thing but I
definitely did review it
didn't love it
didn't love it but you know
it was all right
it was all right and they're talking
about Christmas movies man it's almost
time to see die hard again
yeah I gotta pick out like I said I kind
of I don't want to watch some like new
Christmas movies I feel like that's I
watched red snow like I'd so I gotta put
up a review of that one
and I want to watch that new one that's
on shutter
and if I if I can find violent night
somewhere maybe we'll watch that one too
that'd be cool
that's like saying one hour photo is a
Christmas film
I mean technically
uh but yeah so are we ready to get into
like some some Christmas bummers I've
been ready you been ready been ready
just waiting on you are you just over
there waiting on you being cranky and
I'm not being cranky and moving around
me moving around is being cranky that's
just moving around
okay okay okay Richard Brown said the
children I reviewed that one for sure
like if that's the British one right
from 2007 2008 something like that
that's a great that's a great movie I
like that one a lot I've seen that one a
couple times I think I reviewed it last
year like last Christmas around there
somewhere
all right
so the first thing that I want to talk
about is I can't believe when we did the
Christmas show about horrible Christmas
murders last year whenever it was I
somehow
um didn't hear about this one maybe
because it's like older this is like
actually 19th century
but
this is pretty [ __ ] up
Oscar says tones of Terror is the best
Channel somebody asked I don't remember
if it was you
but somebody asked if I was gonna keep
doing those because I hadn't put up a
book review like probably in like a week
and a half because usually I put them up
once a week but I got like really behind
on my reading like I'm in the middle of
a book right now and I'm just having I
haven't had time to finish it and like
do a review of it yet but hopefully I
get at least one like book review put up
before the end of this before Christmas
God damn it because I have like a book
of Christmas horror stories that I
wanted to read also but I want to finish
the one that I was in the middle of also
which is kind of not a Christmas book
but whatever it just took me so long to
read it that I didn't really plan for it
to go for at Christmas time because it's
not a Christmas book but whatever
um but yeah so this is a a multiple
murder that happened uh around Christmas
that I somehow didn't hear about before
today
even though it's it seems a fairly well
known I don't know how well known it is
thank you very much granthers may your
Christmas be frightful and Bleak just
thanks it already is
just kidding thanks for another year of
great shows Bridget well yeah we
appreciate that very much we we try we
try to entertain you guys so this is uh
the Ashland tragedy from 1881 have you
ever heard of that no I had never heard
of it before today or yesterday or
whenever it was that I was doing the
notes of this kind of thing I'm like how
the [ __ ] did I miss this kind of thing
this is exactly like right up my alley
because I really love True Crime stuff
and I specifically really like True
Crime like old school like 19th century
True Crime
so yeah so this happened right around
Christmas uh Eve uh 1881. in Ashland
Kentucky
so there's a woman named Mrs Gibbons J.W
Gibbons
and she was I don't know where she was
she was visiting somebody else like she
went away to visit family or something
like that on December 23rd of 1881. now
she left at home she had an 18 year old
son named Robert
a 14 year old daughter named Fanny and
there's another woman or another young
girl that was staying there 17 year old
Emma Thomas who was like a friend of
theirs or you know a friend of the
family or something like that she was
just staying there
so Mrs Gibbons goes somewhere on
December 23rd it's December 24th
like later in the afternoon she comes
back home and finds that her home has
been burned to the ground and all three
of the people in the house are dead
so what ended up happening was that
apparently on the morning of Christmas
Eve December 24th at around five in the
morning
neighbors noticed that the Gibbons house
was on fire
so a couple of them were able to go in
there and drag the bodies out uh you
know Unfortunately they were all already
dead by the time that they discovered it
but when they pulled everybody out they
discovered that not only uh were they
already dead when they pulled out of the
fire but they had already been dead
before the fire even started because
they had all been murdered
uh Fanny the 14 year old she had had her
skull crushed by a blunt instrument
Emma it appeared had been strangled and
it looked as though both girls had been
raped
now Robert who was 18.
um he only had one leg he'd actually
lost a leg in a some like a railroad
accident or something like that or like
an accident at work so he only had one
leg what they think happened was that
whoever The Intruders were like came
into the house and then Robert since he
only had one leg and there was only one
of him and they were presuming that
there was several attackers that he
couldn't really you know he wasn't
really a match for them now he did um
apparently kind of try to get out of the
house and like yell for the neighbors or
like warn the neighbors because this
happened in the middle of the night but
before he could do that apparently one
the killer or Killer's kind of uh snuck
up behind him and struck him in the back
of the head with a hatchet
at that point uh all three of the
victims clothing was saturated with coal
oil and the bot and the people were set
on fire but it looked like the fire on
the bodies had gone out
um so they just were like [ __ ] it and
then they went outside and then just
burned the whole house down just you
know I guess they were trying to cover
their tracks or whatever not too
successfully as it turns out
so yeah sitting the house on fire just
called attention to it well yeah
obviously
um Mike says what year was this 1881
1881 in Ashland Kentucky
so obviously this doesn't seem like it
was a real big town so everyone was like
shocked and horrified as you would be
um so they were able to raise a thousand
dollars uh for which probably like that
was a [ __ ] ton of money back then for
you know information leading to the
arrest of the Killer and they also hired
the town also hired a private detective
named John Norris
now because the Crowbar which had been
used to beat the one girl to death and
the ax or Hatchet that had been used to
kill Robert
um belonged to the family
so they figured well The Killers must
have known
the family are known the layout of the
house because they must have known like
where this stuff was so they could like
go in there and get it right
now the private detective Norris he his
first supposition which not too crazy he
thought that the killer was actually Mrs
Gibbons husband
now the husband was kind of um a drunk
and he'd actually been kicked out of the
house like several weeks earlier because
I guess his wife was like through
putting up with his [ __ ] or whatever
now uh so that was kind of the first
like I said that's not crazy because you
know a lot of times it's husband and it
seemed kind of like a personal Vendetta
type of crime now I was reading this
thing about it that said the community
found it hard to believe that Gibbons
would rape his own 14 year old daughter
I'm like
why did they find that hard to believe
that kind of [ __ ] happens all the time
they had never heard of that I guess not
I mean I was like oh you sweet summer
child but uh yeah well that's not common
I know but I'm just saying that the fact
like nowadays I don't think anybody
would be shocked like that that happened
different Overton window I guess so yeah
um
people know that that happens now
sometimes so but I I think it's unlikely
although also it's unlikely it's more
likely that it was
somebody who knew them
they knew that they were there they knew
that there were two girls there that
they were that they liked and that the
mom was gone although well I don't know
because well you know we'll get into it
or they just didn't care if the mom was
there or not yeah and um they may have
been known
because they must have talked their way
into the house
they talked their way into the access of
those two murder weapons
so they came in there probably on a
friendly visit at first or some kind of
a ruse
and then it and then it went that way
yeah it may have not have been planned
because if it was planned they would
have brought murder weapons
well see that's kind of the one and this
doesn't always happen but anybody that
knows a lot about true crime or is like
in an investigation techniques or
anything like that I mean anytime
somebody is killed with something that
was just there at the scene like any
time oh she was strangled with her own
shoelaces or something like that that's
usually a case of somebody that didn't
wasn't gonna murder the person but then
like something changed in the middle of
the commission Target of opportunity and
it wasn't planned right
because I you see it happen sometimes
too like um you know some cases that
I've written about there were like rape
cases and then like you see that the you
know that the victim was strangled like
I said with their own shoelaces or
nylons or something like that and I said
that was usually probably somebody that
wasn't going to kill the woman
they were just gonna rape them but then
like after in the middle they decided
they were going to kill them because
they fought back or they were like oh
she can identify me because she took my
mask off or something like that so it's
usually something like that because
usually I mean usually if you were like
serious like [ __ ] professional about
it or something like that you'd bring
your own [ __ ] right yeah their kit yeah
but um
yeah it just sounds like a target of
opportunity what's called a disorganized
killers
the yeah they went over there and saw
and then things started to go bad and it
didn't go the way those guys wanted it
to go and they said they attacked
somebody you know they didn't know it
was going to go that way or maybe one of
them didn't know
but I think there's multiple guys
well they I mean yeah but yeah I haven't
got to the end of it yet so so you'll
you'll find out there's too many people
for one guy yeah I mean there's three
people in the house it was two girls and
one guy I mean the guy like that who was
18 and we only had one leg but I mean
still
now he may have had a pistol he could
control three people that way
but then he just killed one of them by
bashing and then strangled the other one
it's kind of I don't know maybe just
didn't want to use the pistol I don't
know
it's unlikely
more likely it's multiple guys and it's
kind of a thing of opportunity
but so like for a time
um you know like I said because the
private investigator was kind of going
down the
you know down the road of it being Mr
Gibbons like the husband who's been
kicked out of the house now there were
like some newspaper stories that came
out that had been attributed to Mrs
Gibbons like the wife that she was
saying that
her husband J.W Gibbons was like super
unstable like a drunk
um that he had spells of temporary
insanity like acting like a loon all the
time
um in the the papers reported that she
said that he had threatened to kill the
family that he was gonna cut their heads
off and he was going to burn the house
down like he was doing all this kind of
crazy [ __ ] and all this other kind of
stuff
so the private detective is out looking
for the dude and you know thinking well
he he supposedly was like suicidal and
all this stuff was like well if he
hasn't killed himself uh so far like
we'll catch him like not too long
because they pretty much know who who it
is but most of the people in town though
I kind of feel like they didn't really
think that that's who it was you know
what I mean now in the next town over
the cops actually arrested a guy named
Willis Hockaday who was a black man
and he had been drinking on the day of
the murder and nobody knew where he was
that night
and I guess when they picked him up for
doing something else he made some
statements that maybe made the cops
think that he maybe he knew something
about it like they were kind of like
incriminating
but there wasn't any other uh evidence
to tie him into the murder although he's
very lucky that he escaped being lynched
because uh Lynch Mob was gathering too
yeah to take matters into their to take
matters into their own hands even though
literally the only the guy was just
drunk and couldn't remember where he was
like that night still drinking while
black that's a Lynch in a fence well
yeah and that's that's kind of what they
were saying I said you gotta watch it
especially back then where was that
Kentucky yeah Kentucky yeah big time Big
Time yeah he didn't do it though
no he didn't yeah so far from what
you're telling me I think the dad did it
I thought you just said you didn't think
that Dad did it well no
you came out later and said yeah but I
haven't read yeah but I haven't finished
the story yet okay see you're just
you're just jumping to jump into your
conclusions before you have all the
information and later you said well he
made threats of burning the house down
and cutting no I said the newspaper
reported that and attributed it to the
wife but I haven't finished my story
okay okay I haven't finished my story
this is the whole story maybe some
yellow journalism involved yeah that's a
whole story like I said that's why you
can't you're you're always trying to
like solve [ __ ] before you know all the
information yeah okay
Jenny's always trying to hold this [ __ ]
back it's good because it don't hold on
because I'm telling a story I can't give
all the facts at once all right see I'm
turning around now
you start turning my back on a show
I'm good grafter says uh grafter dealt
with many criminals over 27 years of
chasing criminals 95 of them don't plan
ahead they just do whatever lizard brain
thoughts come into their low functioning
heads I believe it yeah I believe it
well I think that's why people have a
fascination with
serial killers like you know old BTK and
stuff like that because he was like he
super planned that [ __ ] most of the time
I kind of feel like they don't those
dudes are all [ __ ] graded on a damn
scale well yeah
he was no genius either
I didn't say he was I just said that he
planned [ __ ] yeah
whereas a lot of them don't plan [ __ ]
there's a genius on the [ __ ] dumbass
criminal scale yeah
which is a pretty low bar to clear yeah
yeah pretty low particular yeah
so uh so yeah
now uh as I was saying
um so the statements that appeared in
the newspaper that were all about the
husband's Behavior like acting like a
nut like cutting off their heads and all
this other kind of stuff
turns out uh that Mrs Gibbons didn't say
any of that [ __ ] or she saw it or she
said some [ __ ] that was a lot milder
than that and the newspaper reporter
like wildly exaggerated it like to sell
newspapers
so it turned out that uh the husband J.W
Gibbons he comes back to Ashland on
January 2nd and he had an airtight Alibi
that he was someplace else so it
obviously was not him so like I said I
kind of feel like now some of the people
in the town knew it wasn't him like from
the start
so I'm just saying in the newspaper I'm
not sure exactly what the wife said
um but she came out later and she said I
didn't say any of that crazy [ __ ] that
was in the paper that they attributed to
me that I said that he was like said he
was going to cut our heads off and
dancing around with a knife and all that
other kind of stuff so I'm guessing that
like the newspapers just exaggerated
what she said and I don't know what it
was that she said you know what I mean
but it was clearly like a lot milder
than what they fake news
pretty much big news pretty much
so um the Ashland Police Department uh
you had the detective detective Heflin
was his name uh he actually never
believed that JW Gibbons was the killer
he uh had his eye on these other people
so the night of January 2nd which was
the same night that Gibbons had come
back into town and like proved that he
was you know somewhere else the
detective arrested three dudes William
Neal Ellis Kraft and George Ellis
so he brings them into custody I'm not
sure entirely like why he suspected them
the whole time I guess because you know
I don't know they were around or there
was like some kind of other suspicion
about them or something
so George Ellis one of the three guys
who was a bricklayer
he pretty much uh as soon as he was
taken into custody uh he caved he
immediately admitted yeah I was at the
that house that night of the murders but
um it mostly wasn't me it was the other
two guys that's but at this point like
what what are you gonna do right
he said that the other two guys
um William Neal and Ellis Craft
that their whole thing was they had they
they were um boasting that they were
going to quote unquote carnally No
the two girls that were announced the
two teenagers before Christmas that was
their goal apparently
they had lofty go uh I suppose so so he
says so Ella says that they woke him up
like late that night which was you know
Christmas Eve Eve I guess and he's like
you have to go with us to Gibbon's house
we're gonna do this [ __ ]
so he says he went with them but like
reluctantly I'm like yeah I'm sure
so he said that they broke in through a
window or crawled in through a window I
don't know if it was unlocked or
something and Ellis said that he watched
as one of the guys raped the 14 year old
and then the other guy like rapes the 17
year old and George Ellis said that he
didn't rape her but that he held her
arms like while it was going on
now Apparently after the rape like the
17 year old girl said I know who you are
and I'm gonna tell my mom at which case
you know that was probably not the
smartest thing to say not blaming the
victim I'm just saying I don't know if
she really said that and we're just
going by what the killer said
now uh apparently like the sound of his
sister and the friend that was also
staying in the house like you know
screaming and yelling that woke up
Robert the 18 year old and he went out
and he tried to get out of the house
like to yell for help and that was when
craft the other guy like hit him in the
head with an ax and like killed him so
he was killed during all this raven yeah
or like or immediately afterward like
during or immediately afterwards how
long does it take these these dudes must
be quick man
but they just put it in and then they're
done there's not enough time there
I don't know
yeah because you got to rape two women
right well it was two guys well they
were each raping a separate a different
one
yeah but you know how long are we
talking about because I don't know the
the
brother
or the one girl is gonna wake up and
then they're gonna have to stop what
they're doing and kill that dude then
they're gonna have to get back to
[ __ ] raping time according to that dude
for the Predators remember him yeah yeah
I don't know I'm just telling you what
the what the dudes did the the timeline
sounds funny to me
that's what he said there it didn't go
down that way
maybe not well the thing about it is
that I think the guy that confessed to
the cops yeah was probably more involved
than he was letting on you know what I
mean because he was all just very much
like oh well I was there and like you
know he he didn't deny being there but I
think he tried to like uh you know kind
of minimize his involvement he went in
there and had to take over first
you know what I mean to keep to keep
everybody under control I have to do
that first and they killed that dude
then they raped those two girls
that's what they did
yeah it might have been I mean they
might have killed him first yeah because
I mean the thing about it like I said if
the girls were screaming and that guy
you know if he saw that there was three
guys in the house and he knew that he
wouldn't be able to like best them he
probably would have tried to like run
outside to like get the neighbors or
whatever and then they like and a third
dude watched that one girl make sure she
didn't run while they were the two were
raping that other girl and then when
they were done raping her that other guy
probably he went in there and got some
too and then when they were all three
were done with her then they strangled
her to death
and the other one that was waiting
outside that they had out there in the
living room or whatever she didn't know
that the other girl got killed she
didn't hear it because they're probably
told him that that they would let him
live
so they're probably using mind games on
them
yeah because the one was strangled and
then the other one was actually like
beaten to death with a crow yeah she was
the last one because they had time and
safety the other two people were dead so
they could take time
doing that so then they just said here
and then they boom started beating her
maybe she said something that pissed him
off and they started into that
well
um yeah that's the thing I think um one
of them said that she knew who the guys
were and we're gonna like and she was
trying out what she said though no I'm
just saying probably said something to
him that really pissed him off
call it like said about their micro dick
or something or just you know like you
guys are [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] you're gonna hang and that kind
of [ __ ] you know and then then they
started fighting you know and he's like
yeah you little deck [ __ ] and
then they [ __ ] boom boom boom boom
boom beat her to death
it's [ __ ] up
yeah
these are criminals uh clearly stupid
[ __ ] yeah
so uh they couldn't get it any other way
they probably didn't have any damn
skills yeah I mean they have to steal it
they have to rape women they just can't
get it the legitimate way
they're not gonna be able to talk their
way into it
don't have enough money to buy their way
into it they don't have anything you
know they're losers
well then they should just use their
[ __ ] hand and leave everybody else
alone it's very rare it's very rare that
these guys are some kind of fetishist I
mean there are there have been guys who
are serial rapists who were acceptable
had good looking guys had money
had girlfriends and whole relationships
but they just had this thing where they
had to rape women they had a couple of
those well yeah because there's there
are things right yes it's like a sexual
fetish
and you look at the dude he's just like
captain of the football team Mr Biff you
know just jock boy you know from a
[ __ ] wealthy family and [ __ ] and he's
raping rich girls basically
yeah I think that happens more uh
commonly than we'd like to believe yeah
they got that guy a guy I was thinking
about that would happen sometime in the
90s and I think he got like 20 or 30 of
them and um I think I know who you're
talking who he was and everything he was
hiding out on those damn vacation
Islands you know they didn't have
certain uh didn't didn't have certain
extradition laws but then they he
eventually raped some girl down there
and I think they got him or killed him
or something
I don't remember what it was back in the
90s remember he was he was a young guy
his 20s
yeah I mean I I vaguely remember what
you're talking about but I just you know
I don't know I don't know like offhand
yeah I forgot I don't remember the guy's
name I could kind of see his face that's
it yeah just kind of generic I was gonna
say it's like they all kind of look like
a generic Force they all kind of like I
saw shirt stripes and [ __ ] you know it's
right little white shorts and his little
[ __ ] slipper looking [ __ ] shoes
you know what I mean [ __ ] that
haircut
you know yeah
Country Club looking [ __ ] yeah yeah
name is Big yeah he wasn't
he wasn't you know a little scrawny dude
he was [ __ ]
he was a chad
but he's just into violent rapes
well yeah like I said I don't that that
doesn't surprise me at all because
to an extent I kind of feel like rape
isn't usually about sex really it's
about power it's about having power over
someone
like and a lot of people get off on that
like I think it's a sexual fetish for
the dude
um and that's it's like BDSM basically
it's the fact that he's forcing her he's
getting off on that
well yeah I think that's pretty common
yeah and uh his girlfriend like had no
idea she didn't believe it you know she
she couldn't accept it that that's who
he was
because he had a girlfriend and
everything he was yeah he was popular
popular with women Ted Bundy had a
girlfriend too yeah
well like I said the dude was popular
with women
yeah and they didn't want to accept it
like I said so it's not necessarily just
somebody that can't get it any other way
something yeah somebody gets off on just
get off on it right on forcing people to
do what they don't what but he was the
exception though he wasn't that he
wasn't Baseline Baseline dude it's a
loser
Mike said what are you guys drinking
vodka and lemonade
Tom was thinking about getting some
eggnog I got the eggnog I don't know if
I want to spike the eggnog do you have
anything to put into eggnog do you have
any rum or anything I don't have any rum
I just had to put vodka in it vodka can
go in it yeah that's I know but it's
usually people put rumors
or bourbon not a big difference in the
flavor of [ __ ] not really white vodka
and white from white rum and vodka about
the same that's true I think rum might
be vodka
I think it's just different form of
vodka I think it made it just made a
different way
well then it's not right yeah it's made
in a different way
I think it's the same thing except for
the fact that it's totally different
I just gotta they're trying to make fun
whoops
God damn it well put that in the bottle
with the other label on it yeah
it's all good uh Vandal capture 72 said
oh my God your hair looks great thank
you love the goatee I don't know if it's
like I don't know if he needs my hair or
your hair yeah I don't know
you don't have to goatee it's a beard
man
you're looking more and more like uh
Mirror Universe Spock back there yeah
a cross between like Mirror Universe
Spock and Magnum merciless had a baby
yeah which that would be something I'm
gonna make a Ming outfit yeah you should
but I'm gonna do my own [ __ ] my own
reboot of me be nice huh yeah yeah it'll
be jacked man
jacked Ming
I'll just have the cops I want to have a
shirt just [ __ ] bare chest and kind
of like Jesus
[ __ ] tight ass pants
I'll sit in the damn Throne over there
at [ __ ] um you can take a picture of
that that'll be my name
you like that
May yeah
that's the way Ming should have been
anyway even though Max von said I was a
[ __ ] great man
I mean he was a sexy [ __ ]
walking around [ __ ] eating his little
black olives and [ __ ] watching him
torture his daughter oh no continue the
torture
[ __ ] perverted [ __ ] eating black
olives alien black olives yeah yeah
thanks
no thanks I really imaginary your days
so far too dangerous
let's see
y'all think anything about the soccer
game or was that topic already beat to
death I don't think anybody's talking
because what soccer was never even heard
of it I think it's the World Cup guy
I've never heard of that I think
I don't know I haven't followed it all
the time
I used to kind of know what was going on
because my ex-husband was really into it
but that was a long time ago
so I don't know I thought somebody said
something about the World Cup but yeah
we're Americans we don't care about that
it's not football well I don't I it's
not just that I don't care about sports
at all because football's not football
American football is not the game it was
[ __ ] even 15 years ago
that's boring I don't really give a [ __ ]
about it so they're all boring today
all the sports boring is gay
okay straight dudes shouldn't be
watching that we'll see well the thing
about it is that well yeah
if it it should be gayer though I mean
because if it was a game or at least it
would be more interesting yeah NFL came
out said it was gay they had the big old
NFL thing with all the rainbow stuff
says NFL's gay and they and it still got
all them damn beta beta [ __ ] males
watching that [ __ ] because they're
lusting after them black men running
around what it is that living
vicariously didn't have any sexual ideas
about these black Superior genetic black
men running around those tight ass
[ __ ] pants
what it is ask Zach he knows all about
it
they're right Zach
he's talking about olives little pizza
okay
I'm not really worried about it either
way like I said I always thought like
sports was really boring just generally
I don't mind watching like [ __ ] like
gymnastics and stuff but
here's the [ __ ] thing man nope
those snowbirds are here now okay and
they're going down at a biker bar
and they just stick out like [ __ ]
sore thumbs versus the locals and they
go there and they put the [ __ ]
football game on but but the bikers
don't let them [ __ ] put the volume on
they have to use captions because
they're not getting in the way of that
jukebox
and they'll yell and fight over that
[ __ ] game okay
and you look at those dudes and those
dudes are like they all look alike
they're the least physically fit
[ __ ] of all times you know what
I mean
into the athletic prowess of other men
it's just suspicious it's just very
suspicious to me
I think what happens a lot of times is
well at least like some like family
members that I knew that were that were
really into it were like they sometimes
they would play it in high school but
then like they got you know out of shape
like later like when they got older they
couldn't play anymore
so they just like
I guess they were watching it try to
like relive their Glory Days or
something
I don't know I was looking at those
dudes I don't think those dudes were
ever physically fit the ones that were
sitting there watching well I'm not
talking about I don't know those [ __ ]
dudes I'm talking about like in my
experience yeah you know I'm just
telling you you said what your
experience was I was telling you what my
experience was I've noticed that bikers
don't give a [ __ ] about any of that [ __ ]
or Sports they're just like that well
they're bikers they don't give a [ __ ]
about it no
I mean where I grew up in Daytona
everyone was into NASCAR a lot of people
yeah bikers who watch Nascar a lot of
people were into football too but I kind
of feel like the main thing because I
grew up in Daytona Beach so that's like
a big uh that's where the obviously they
do Daytona 500 so obviously like NASCAR
was like a big thing but bikers are a
big thing too because like I said they
started bike week and bike totally fast
and all those biker bars and [ __ ] so I
could see those bikers watching NASCAR
if they were ever going to watch
anything on TV yeah but they don't seem
to like even TV
and it's okay
you know I don't consider myself a biker
people I have motorcycles but I don't
because there was ugly bar to be a biker
in my mind you got to have a [ __ ]
Harley and really you should be in a
club you should be in a motorcycle then
you're a biker they got them down there
it's like it's it's a [ __ ] warlock
well it's kind of like a whole lifestyle
you know what I mean it's not just kind
of like getting drunk with the warlocks
they're they're just just like anybody
else
I saw a damn little bit of [ __ ] thing
that they did on the warlocks I [ __ ]
on the History Channel and I laugh at
that [ __ ] and I was like okay yeah
that's not what they're like when you
know them
you're just like anybody else in the
[ __ ] bar
but they don't certain questions you
don't ask you know I said hi I said how
many uh said what's a membership how
many members you got in in your chapter
and they went enough
oh okay
but they will tell you how many they
have all right
Tammy said NASCAR is just waiting for
the Rex yeah I feel like that's yeah
because otherwise there's just people
driving really fast at a circle like
that's not really all that exciting to
be honest with you
um but yeah okay so where was I was in
the middle of this story yeah yeah I
know you don't know
[Laughter]
I know you don't know
um so yeah so uh do we even remember
nobody remembers what I was talking
about do they so um so the guy that uh
went that had you know confessed to the
cops
he basically said the reason that he
broke down and confessed right away
because he said that he felt really
really bad like because the way that the
girls had like screamed and stuff when
they were like raping and killing them
and he hadn't been able to sleep since
then and he felt like really really bad
so he just couldn't uh stand it any
longer and that he had just been praying
every day and he was just kind of like I
know that what we did was bad and I'm
just like ready to hang or whatever now
he so he came and said what the story
was but the other two guys were like nah
bro that's not what happened and they
just like totally denied it up and down
so the cops take all three of them on
the steamboat
and they take them to this town called
uh Catlettsburg I'm not entirely sure
like how far away that is
so uh again it was a Lynch Mob
um you know Gathering up like gonna grab
them and like hang them from a tree
someplace
but the cops did actually manage to get
them in jail and like put them safely
away uh before the Lynch Mob got to them
so they actually had 10 armed guards
around the prisoners at the jail and
they did actually manage to keep them
from getting lynched until their kind of
Trials came
now eventually William nail one of the
other guys he did finally confess to the
crime but the third guy Ellis Craft uh
he just swore up and down that they
didn't do it um that he didn't do it and
he just like pled not guilty
uh however all of them were charged with
uh aiding abetting and conspiracy to
commit murder
uh George Ellis who was the one that had
confessed first he was actually
separately charged with three counts of
murder because they were doing like a
technicality because they wanted him I
guess like the law said that he would
have to do that like so he could testify
against the other two guys for some
reason so yeah that's how they did it
so at that point uh Neil got mad and
he's like okay well I'm changing my plea
to not guilty also but as it turned out
all three of the guys were convicted uh
Neil and craft who were the two that
hadn't confessed they were found guilty
of first-degree murder and they were
sentenced to hang Ellis who testified
against the other two he was actually
found guilty of manslaughter so you get
a lesser charge for confessing and he
was sentenced to life in prison
however people in Ashland Kentucky were
not real uh happy about that no
imagining lynched his ass so a group of
40 men with masks on yeah broke into the
jail through the window yeah and uh
dragged him out the jail with a rope
around his neck and hung him from a tree
yeah so that was the confessed dude yep
now uh the other two guys who hadn't
confessed but got convicted anyway they
appealed their convictions and they got
they were granted new trials and they
did like a change of venue because they
argued that they couldn't get a fair
trial where they were
so they took him to another place called
Maysville Kentucky
um there was 220 state troopers like
guarding them because like I said they
just knew that somebody's gonna like
drag out or [ __ ] kill the
[ __ ]
um actually uh when they were in the
steamboat like taking them to the other
venue like a group of guys this is like
[ __ ] 1881 Kentucky you guys a bunch
of people like started opening fire on
the steamboat yeah like trying to kill
the guys just shoot the steamboat up and
then the cop started shooting back at
them yeah so the cops actually killed
one of the one of the guys and wounded a
bunch of the other ones they didn't have
a whole riots Behind These Guys right
and you all think it's crazy now and it
was [ __ ] crazy back in the 1800s I
mean yeah this is [ __ ] crazy like one
of the dudes has already been lynched
and then the other ones they're just
like [ __ ] shooting at him yeah which
I mean I I understand the sentiment I
mean what they did was [ __ ] up right
yeah so um so it turned out that five
Spectators that were along the riverbank
they got killed uh 21 got wounded uh
unfortunately the prisoners uh got there
completely unharmed which is kind of
ironic like a bunch of other people got
hurt but they didn't
um so they got a second trial in a
different venue but uh they did not
Prevail this time around they got
convicted again a first degree murder
and again sentenced to hang
um so one of a Craft's brother who was
trying to keep his brother from being
hanged he goes and
he goes and scares up a black man in
Columbus Ohio who had supposedly
confessed to the crimes it was like
desperately trying to like find somebody
else to pin it on
um what happened was this guy's name was
William dyerly and he uh the story went
that he had given this woman a bracelet
that had supposedly allegedly belonged
to one of the murder girls but nobody
believed this because obviously it was
just a family member trying to keep his
[ __ ] brother from getting hanged or
anything like that so everybody's like
[ __ ] that that dude didn't do anything
um it was also believed that um the
brothers friends or that like the the
friends of craft like the guy that was
gonna get hanged that they were gonna
Lynch that guy the black guy like to
draw attention away from Craft so they
had like all kind of Nefarious plots
going on with this because these were
like [ __ ] [ __ ] bags man
um so the thing about that fair play to
the people of Ashland like they uh
didn't believe obviously that William
dyerly like the black guy had done
anything and they were actually like
super super nice to him
um and they made sure that you know
nothing bad happened to him because they
knew that he was like getting [ __ ]
over because of these miscreants you
know what I mean so they actually did
hang Ellis Craft on October 12 1883.
in Grayson Kentucky
um and a big old crowd came out and had
a [ __ ] party uh when they hanged him
yeah uh and he basically went to the
hangman saying that he was innocent so
I'm not sure I buy that but okay yeah uh
William Neal the the other guy he got
hanged also in Grayson on March 27 1885
uh also professing innocence until his
dying breath but like I said probably
not uh probably not yeah you know what I
mean yeah before we get off the subject
this is this is a good time to uh to
bring up do some clarification
especially this involves a dude that
almost got [ __ ] lynched for drinking
while black but uh most there's a lot of
mainstream misconceptions about lynching
and the clan and all this kind of stuff
modern day Hollywood will tell you that
the clan went around lynching people
most lynchings were not done by clan
members they were just done by regular
townspeople okay usually how it went
down is someone was found guilty of some
kind of a heinous crime they busted in a
mob of people an angry mob were saying
we're not gonna let that [ __ ] go
to jail we're going to kill him or we're
not going to let them hang him we're
going to carry him that that that's how
rudimentary the thinking was David bust
into the damn Courthouse sometimes even
before the dude was found guilty okay uh
grab him take him out and Lynch him
and they take pictures
um whether the guy was white or black
they'd take pictures uh if it was
because they did the same thing to white
people especially those crimes against
women and children yeah that was it was
a black guy
a lot of times what would happen is clan
members are run out there and try to
take pictures with with the people
because they would take pictures along
with the body
which kind of when you go back and look
at those old pictures makes it look like
the clan did it clan didn't do it clan
was just trying to take credit for it
because that's that's the way their
thinking was really it was just the
townspeople did it
um so it was a lot more widespread in
the South you know you can't just put
all that on the den on the damn Clan the
clan was bad but the townspeople were
bad too
it was just kind of the the way people
were at the time they were yeah I mean
I'm not obviously
um you know that's a very problematic uh
lynching is very problematic like what
is whoever it is like we even if it's a
criminal or something in this case
uh you know it's still not you should
have let the trial go through I guess
but it's like I I have less prob because
they probably did do it I mean it seems
like it was a southern thing and if you
go back in time and read the way
Southerners were even in the early 1900s
they were known as being very emotional
and they weren't very legalistic and it
would be like that's I did you know this
is not right you know what I mean the
law is wrong you know we're right you
know is that kind of show this we're
going to take matters in our own on our
own hands God is on our side or just
whatever you know what I mean they would
get emotional in a big [ __ ] mob and
kill somebody who maybe wasn't even
found guilty yet because they believed
that that person was guilty well yeah
you know which is that's [ __ ]
dangerous man uh yeah big time and you
know and I'm like Mass psychosis well
and I'm sure that well because a lot of
times and I've written about some cases
particularly ones that happened like in
the early 20th century where you know
somebody gets arrested for a crime and
everybody like flips out about it it's
like oh my God like let's kill this guy
or like try to Lynch that guy and then
it fine then you find out later on that
it wasn't him like it was some other
random [ __ ] yeah and so like
yeah if they lynched that guy that was a
totally innocent person if the guy got
found guilty that Edgar mob all of a
sudden felt Justified okay now we can
kill him and they'd [ __ ] break into
the damn Courthouse or the jail with the
jail the courthouse are usually the same
thing these little towns these are the
little towns they might have five cops
and they can't fight off a hundred
people with guns okay and they'd go out
there and they'd grab that dude [ __ ]
hot a haul him outside just hang him
right there
even even if he was sentenced to hang
anyway
a lot of times they were already
sentenced to hang
but it was just
the thinking of the time you know they
were was it happening fast enough it
wasn't happening fast enough for them
they wanted Vengeance uh a very
emotional based people
um
uh if you look at photographs
of the lint because they would take
photographs if you looked at the
photographs of the lynching scenes and
just look at the people
it's not even like it's the same country
it was like a third world country
malnourishment and the people you can
see it poverty poor the IQs weren't very
high you know
I probably am breeding too you know
but it's just uh you know the world is a
developing world you know America was
way underneath what India would be today
at that time you know and weird [ __ ]
happens in India and India would be
Advanced compared to the United States
at this time that we're talking about
so
that's where humans are about humans are
dangerous
difficult to control
especially when they're dumb
yeah you gotta watch this dumb people
dumb people yeah
there's Demetrios hello is it really you
is it really
they had somebody in here impersonating
your wife last night well I kind of feel
like that's why he came in and said that
because that's similar to what she said
last night yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
you know and then sticking the tongue
out um we're still trying to figure out
who that is we don't know if it's like
I'm gonna make us another drink I didn't
know if it was somebody who's stalking
us or stalking you guys or nah we don't
really know it was well I don't know it
was just weird it was just weird and it
was weird too and we were saying that
earlier because like whoever this was
that was impersonating her like they
didn't say anything [ __ ] up or nothing
like that they just said one thing and
it was just like
sounded like something she would have
said so we didn't really like worry
about it
Mike says uh Jenny do you like Italian
or American Horror both of them I like
all horror really you know but it's I'll
watch any of it from anywhere if it's
good I do like I do particularly like uh
Italian horror though I really like uh
Gela movies and stuff but I like lots of
different kinds so you know uh yeah Hugo
said uh lynching was a spectacle back in
the day yeah I kind of feel like up
until you know relatively modern times
you know it was kind of a big deal to
like go out and see somebody executed
hey let's go to the witch burn anger hey
let's go to the hanging or something
like that which you know
seems like kind of [ __ ] up it's kind
of [ __ ] up
you know what I mean
take let's take the kids and like a big
picnic lunch and like watch the people
get burned alive
this is like messed up and it didn't
like make I don't know I just kind of
feel like it was just done for like
entertainment purposes I'm sure they
Justified it by saying it's like oh it's
a deterrent to Crime it's like obviously
it wasn't because the [ __ ]
I I think it actually just made people
probably like a lot more
you know indoor do it what you doing
people just um you know just
public executions oh yeah yeah it's
violent man people were very violent
that's what I'm saying it's like and I'm
sure like they probably Justified it by
saying it like deterred crime but I'm
like yeah I probably had the opposite
effect I would think
I don't know it probably didn't really
matter
I think people did whatever they wanted
to do anyway they tried to get away with
whatever they tried you know it was uh
this was the hood you know
everywhere it was the hood
all right so
um the second uh Christmas disaster that
we're gonna talk about is one it's
probably like slightly a little bit
better now and I kind of feel like
but this was the Italian Hall disaster
this happened in 1913
and this was actually uh the largest
this is okay
this needs a little bit of uh a caveat
they call it the largest mining related
disaster to occur in Michigan
but it wasn't a mine cave-in or it
wasn't anything like that it didn't
actually happen in a mine it was just
like mining related but it is like
really really bad hey Pokemon yeah what
are we gonna grab it no you don't she
doesn't want to be on a show I don't
want to be on a show yeah she never
likes me on the show
well she just doesn't like being like
grabbed and like oh I do it all day long
well I know but I mean maybe she just
likes about this room yeah she's like
actually in there I like to be like free
to like walk around yeah I like to be
free to walk around yeah I think each
room represents a different state of
mind
in the cat it seems like when when I'm
in the bedroom watching stuff
like a wrestle with her put her on my
lap and she likes that but I'm in here
and then here I guess it's more like
playroom
because you got all the toys so she
doesn't want to be picked up in here
well in here too she's Brushy and also
yeah jumping up on mommy's desk and yeah
falling asleep on her keyboard or
licking the keyboard only certain things
happen in certain rooms room has a
different function then out in the
living room is catching threat is
throwing things throwing things and
catching things she likes to play with
like her chicken and stuff like yeah and
like she's like grab it
yeah so yeah she's got like a little
workstation yeah she's got like little
activity stations little little Pookie
activities yeah Tammy says pookie
all right
so yeah the Italian Hall disaster
considered the largest mining related
disaster even though it didn't happen in
an actual mine but I'll get into that in
a little bit
so
um this happened in a little bitty town
called Calumet Michigan not really sure
if you know where that is it's um it's
right next to the Overlook
I know but yeah that was in the damn
storehouse it was but that's yeah that's
like that's like some other [ __ ] but
yeah um this was in the key oh it's
Kiwana kiwanap peninsula
Sophie's the sufi's not here she's from
Michigan she could have told me from
Michigan oh that's right that's right
yeah grafters is here
um yeah so the shitty thing about this
is that
this
um was a mining accident that actually
ended up affecting like the women and
children like the wives and the children
of the miners like more than the actual
miners
so uh it happened on Christmas Eve
uh back in 1913 as I mentioned
now before the town was called Calumet
it was actually called red jacket and
the main
company there that employed a large
number of people in the town was like a
copper mine it was like a big copper
mining operations
um so red jacket the town was like a
company town which like I said if you
don't know what that is that's like you
know a big mine or a big industrial
Factory type thing would open and then
they would essentially build a town
around it to house all of their
employees
um you know so a lot of people didn't
really
they're a little bit exploitative I
guess because it's just kind of like
they end up you know the company opens
like a company store and like houses and
stuff like that so you're pretty much
working for the company but they're
you're also like giving money back to
them because you're buying [ __ ] from
their store and paying them rent like
for your house and all this other kind
of stuff so that's kind of like what
this situation was
so uh this place was called the Heckler
Calumet and Heckler Mining Company
this was a copper mine
um in the 1870s known as the world's
largest copper producer and had the
deepest copper mines at least at that
time
but um right around this time period
obviously there was a lot of uh push for
unionization you know like uh organized
labor and stuff like fighting for
because at this point they didn't have
um you know a minimum wage they didn't
have like uh you know
standard hours like they could work like
really long hours you didn't like have a
lot of Rights you know what I mean so
there was like a lot of push to unionize
and uh this kind of place you know the
the workers at this mine were no
different there were a lot of them going
on strike and things like that
so in 1913
miners in Colorado and in Montana had
unionized and in uh July of that same
year in 1913 uh the Western Federation
of minors um actually called for a
strike against all the Copper Country
mines they were actually pushing for a
three dollar a day wage
um eight hour days because like I said
you didn't you know you they could work
you as long as they wanted pretty much
back then
um safer working conditions [ __ ] like
that
so the strike had been going on for a
while like it started in July and then
like it went on into the fall and on
into the winter
and as Christmas was approaching there
was uh the women's auxiliary group of
the western Federation of minors and
they put together a Christmas Eve party
for all of the miners families and this
was at a place called The Italian
benevolent Society building better known
as the Italian hall for short
so it was a big huge party
um they it's it was like several stories
I think it was a three-story building if
I'm remembering the pictures correctly
um there were probably more than 600
people inside there uh they had like a
bunch of stuff they had like a play and
they had like all the presents for the
kids and all kind of food laid out and
stuff like a big Christmas party you
know what I mean
um yeah the the people that you know the
organizer said that it was like such a
big party that they couldn't even like
keep track of who the [ __ ] was going in
and out because it was just so many
people there
so at the height of the party uh
somebody
yelled fire
so as what happened in that situation
with all those people in there
um pretty much everybody panicked
and started running for the exits
so they started trying to get out
through the stairwell
um somebody tripped uh or started to
fall over like in the steps and stuff
like that um at which point a bottleneck
was created and people just started
falling one on top of the other
um and nobody could get out essentially
so uh yeah lots and lots of people were
killed uh and the the ironic thing was
there wasn't actually a fire
and one of the things about it that
it kind of because Woody Guthrie wrote a
song about it later
The Story Goes that they think that like
some anti-union person had come in there
and like yelled fire like just for shits
and giggles or like to see what would
happen or something like that nobody
knows if that's the case somebody yelled
fire that's for sure and everybody
panicked even though there wasn't a fire
you know what I mean and they're like
well it's possible too that it could
have been
maybe somebody thought there was a fire
you know maybe they weren't being like
nefarious and they just actually did
think they thought they were helping but
um as it happened like I said there
wasn't actually a fire but so many
people tried to get out through the
exits and like people got trampled and
like a bunch of people got killed uh
many of whom were children
so they had to pull all the dead bodies
like out of this huge pile in the
stairwell where like I said they had all
kind of like fallen over one another and
like people had smothered and like you
know were trampled and stuff
so they carried them all out to the town
hall and that was just like a big morgue
um you know to people's it was awful
like because like I said it was mostly
Women and Children of the miners you
know so they had to like send for all
these [ __ ] uh coffins
because they said the article I was
reading said you know even this was that
this was a mining town and obviously
there's like a lot of accidents and
stuff so you'd think that they'd have
like this is gonna sound [ __ ] up but
you'd think they'd had enough coffins
laying around but they didn't so they
had to like Rush some like from other
towns and stuff
so
um it's and it seems like this town too
like after it happened like people were
flipping out because like I said the the
mine
um ownership and the you know Union were
like at odds and because the story went
around whether it was true or not that
some anti-union representative or
somebody that worked for the mining
company had come in there and yelled
fire and made everybody Panic like that
um they you know that so there was like
a lot of um contention like between the
two groups and there's still a little
bit of it like now like it even like
remains as far as I know because they
still have like a memorial there and
they still put out candles like every
Christmas Eve and stuff
um and they said that even
uh a couple days after it happened like
there was these writers there from like
a Finnish newspaper and they printed a
story that said that the calling the
deaths murder because somebody had come
in there and like yelled that on purpose
like to make everybody freak out and um
those writers got arrested like for
saying that
so they had this massive [ __ ] uh you
know this massive funeral and all this
other stuff 20 000 Spectators showed up
um all these other you know uh you know
Union people from all around like came
and [ __ ] like that and I'm trying to
like look like I said the it's probably
famous mostly famous because the Woody
Guthrie song about it
I think in the song and this these were
like rumors that went around too not
just that the like the person that
yelled fire that they didn't even know
who it was but there were also like
rumors that the doors in the Italian
Hall were designed to open inward which
you know people said oh it's like was
this nefarious thing so if there ever
was actually a fire like no one could
get out
um but that turned out not to be the
case and I think that there were some
rumors going around too that like people
that the doors did open outward but that
like people were on the other side like
pushing against it like to keep people
from coming out and I think that was
like debunked also
but um you know like I said emotions
were pretty uh were pretty high after
this incident as as you know they
probably would be
so they actually tore down uh the old
Italian Hall in 1984 and they kind of
like they did like a park at the site in
like a memorial and stuff and I think
that they just put a new Memorial there
like in 2017 or 2018 or something like
that I was trying to look because I
thought I had in my notes here like how
many people had died in the thing but I
don't think this I don't think my note
said actually
it was quite a lot but it was mostly
like children like women and children
because like I said it was like the
families of the minors that were there
but that was all because you know how um
you know when they when people talk
about like oh you know restrictions
about free speech and it's like you
don't have like you know uh the right to
like yell fire in a crowded theater this
is the this is what they're talking
about this is the case that they're
talking about because somebody came in
and did that even though there wasn't a
fire and everybody panicked and like
started running for the exits and they
all got trampled like mostly like a
bunch of little kids and taught us about
this case in third grade man [ __ ]
Elementary Dominguez Elementary School
remember yeah that's when they talk
about this yeah and the lesson was just
don't yell for fire in a crowded theater
that they were telling us that you know
don't don't tetsuo says 73 people died
59 of which were children yeah yeah it's
weird I kind of I could have sworn that
I wrote down the numbers up there but
then when I was looking I couldn't see
it but I was having problems with my
computer earlier so we might as well it
might have like [ __ ] erased it it was
funny that they would teach little kids
about this case even in the third grade
that's funny that you remember that you
learned about it like I think that I
think that we learned about it but I
think it was a little bit later than
that I don't think I learned about it in
elementary school I think I learned
about I learned about elementary school
I think it had something to do with
responsibilities of like crying wolf and
telling the truth and [ __ ] you know
and how lies can get people killed that
that that's what the lesson was but it's
a long time but I remember they told us
about this case that you can't you can't
yell fire in a crowded theater and you
can't [ __ ] say something happened
when it didn't happen you know they
education was different back then I
remember I remember well I think that's
a good I mean this is a good um this is
a good story to illustrate that and it
like actually did happen yeah and like I
said it's not even a case because they
don't really know if the person that
yelled fire because they know somebody
did but they don't know if that person
did it on purpose to get everybody to
Panic or if they legitimately thought
there was a fire for whatever reason and
so they were just or and so they were
just mistaken yeah I mean I kind of feel
like people were pretty quick to
attribute I guess like I said because
there had been so much contention
between uh you know the union organizers
and the company and the company owners
that people just jumped to the
conclusion well that must have been
somebody that came in and did that on
purpose which it's possible that that
did happen but that's like the
conclusion most people jump to but I
mean like I said it is still possible
that somebody legitimately did think
there was a fire you know maybe they
just saw some smoke from somewhere and
they thought they were saving everybody
but that's not what happened you know so
that's kind of a bummer all right so uh
the next one we want to talk about
actually maybe I want to take a break
yeah let me run to the bathroom Okay
real quick now I'm gonna put some
commercials on yeah the commercials are
all linked together aren't they well
there's two of them there's C can you
see it uh not my glasses on I can see it
from here I guess it says commercial
string One commercial string two yeah
can you see that I could see them kind
of you can kind of see it yeah all right
well I'm gonna go to the bathroom
pick one and two see okay yeah one is
all right I'll do that [ __ ] right now
you ready yeah you guys tell me if you
guys see this okay you guys too
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
indicate
with the death of him
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
one day
[Music]
foreign
we're back yep I know I was I was just
telling Tom I was like I went in the
bathroom just now and like I closed
doors because that bathroom has two
doors and I closed both the doors and
then I turned around and like pookie was
on the
the bath mat like the shower or the
little shower rug or whatever which is
the same color as her and so I didn't
see her she was like hiding on there I
was like and I was like get out of here
and so on she's so weird she does that
to me sometimes like sometimes if I get
up in the middle of the night like to go
pee she like she'll be that I really
can't see her then because then it's
dark so she just like smooshes down like
in the middle of the thing and she's
like hey she can't see me
laughs
anyway all right so uh so yeah I had
some little commercials there yeah it
gives you guys a break give everybody a
break yeah so we can run to the bathroom
without just looking at an empty chair
yep so I can't believe that we've only
been going for like two hours yeah
that's the show and I only have we're
behind two a show shouldn't be longer
than two hours Jenny will do a four hour
show if she doesn't give a [ __ ]
well it's not that it's not that I don't
give a [ __ ] it's just that sometimes I
want to go that's good I want to get to
all the material yeah and sometimes we
get off on Side Tracks and I can't get
to all the material no it's going along
with going along nicely yeah okay well
like I said it still looks like a
Christmas special like I said it's like
it's like the Christmas special but it's
not like special special Christmas
special
because I feel like well that one will
be Friday night because then we can just
talk about it it's kind of like the
Vodka that's a little bit like rum but
they make it differently
not exactly because it's I mean it's
wrong it's the same thing and they make
it differently
[Laughter]
well you know a cake and a meatloaf it's
the same thing but they just make it
differently
it's got a completely different
ingredients
but fundamentally it's the same thing
[Laughter]
I can't help it I come from like a huge
line of I mean everyone in my entire
family is smart asses yeah it's genetic
okay so it's like there's not I mean
sarcasm is just kind of like our native
language okay so that's just kind of how
we roll you know what I mean
I you know I I can't help it I can't
help it
uh murder Hornet said I was in Florida
three this afternoon now I'm in Texas
yeah he's over the Panhandle
really that's kind of well it's not that
far from us but it's still kind of far
yeah
how far does it take to drive to the
Panthers try about four or five hours I
think it's like four or five hours from
here or something like that that's kind
of fun
all right so the next Christmas disaster
that we're gonna talk about and I uh
apologize in advance to anybody from New
Zealand because I'm sure I'm gonna like
butcher all of these names
but this is known as oh God I hope I'm
pronouncing this right uh the Tanga y
disaster
this happened in 1953.
and this happened on Christmas Eve of
1953.
and what it was was a Railway Bridge
that was over the
Wang guy who River hopefully that's kind
of right in New Zealand
ended up collapsing under uh a passenger
train like that was while the passenger
train was going across it and it
collapsed from underneath the train
a 151 people
were killed
so the train was this was actually the
3pm express train and it was going from
Wellington to Auckland in New Zealand
so it was the engine like the locomotive
and it had 11 carriages uh four of them
were first class carriages five were
second-class carriages and then it had a
guards van and uh like a post van like
they had mail and stuff in it
um on the train in total we're 285
people uh that included both passengers
and crew what's up Pokey yeah she's
putting up with it she's putting up with
it today she's like you want to be still
yeah I said still look at her little
face
she's putting up with me she's making
mad face she made mad for you yeah I saw
it
maybe it's not mad face it looks like
mad face though you man she kind of went
okay yeah
go ahead and do go ahead and do this
you're so cute
okay so 285 people
so the train is approaching this bridge
that's going across the white guy who
River hopefully I'm pronouncing that
right
um now they knew like afterward that the
driver while it was approaching the
bridge like hit the emergency brakes and
like turn the steam off
so they also shut off the oil supply
valve for the fire so they imagined that
somebody that they either saw that
something was wrong or somebody signaled
to them hey stop or something like that
they're not entirely sure but they're
like they did make an attempt to stop so
they knew that something was the matter
but uh unfortunately it was uh too late
for them to stop
uh so the train goes onto the bridge and
the bridge collapsed from beneath them
uh so the locomotive like the engine on
the front and the five second class
carriages uh went right into the river
uh the first the the first of the first
class carriages kind of like went on the
edge like that and then
um the coupling attaching it to the rest
of the train broke and it fell into the
water also uh there were three first
class carriages that stayed up on the
bridge along with the guards van in the
postal van they got lucky yeah well
first class passengers man that's what
happens
you get to live all the poor people get
to die
um but yeah so that all stayed so all
those people were were okay
so as I mentioned 151 people killed by
this train derailment including the
driver uh and the fire the guy that did
the fire into the you know the coal
thing Nicole dude yeah the cold dude
Cole Porter is that they're called
Nicole Porter that's not what it's
called it said well the or the the
article I read called him the firemen
firemen okay which I was like well
that's a little confusing because that's
also another thing Cole Porter is a guy
who who carries coal right yeah I know
but it's just like I was laughing
because there's also that singer named
Cole Porter oh I didn't know
you know what I mean yeah uh but yeah
not really
what no I don't really know what you
mean
what else is there what else
so yeah uh uh 151 people I'll be 151
people killed 148 of them were
second-class passengers of course uh and
a single first class passenger who got
unlucky because like I said one of the
first class now the ones that went in a
drink did they all instantly die or did
someone live
um you know I think they all pretty much
died and actually they didn't even
recover all the bodies okay like 20 of
the bodies they never found right so
it's just they're down here with that
train well no like they they think that
it went into the river and then they
watched they got washed out like they
did find some of the bodies but not the
20 of them they they have never found
you would think some of them how far was
a drop oh I don't know you'd think
someone would have lived I don't know
man but it's like it's [ __ ] up I mean
it's pretty massive Train's pretty
massive yeah and then hitting the water
is not going to slow it down much and
then it's going to hit the ground so
it's almost gonna be like falling yeah
it's like falling from a high value from
a long height so when it hits the bottom
of that
River it kills you boom you slam into
the damn wall or whatever it is in front
of you bust you out pretty bad I was
just wondering like what was it because
it's not like
they know for sure that the engineer
like the guy that was steering the train
yeah that he had hit the brakes so he
saw something was the matter but it's
like the weird thing is that it wasn't a
case of like oh my God the bridge is out
because it didn't collapse until the
train like went on it because it
couldn't take the weight anymore so it's
really interesting like what what was it
that warned him you know what I mean
that it was not safe maybe the bridge
wasn't straight maybe maybe he saw it
like he they know that he saw something
because he tried to stop like before he
went onto the bridge and it wasn't like
the bridge didn't collapse until the
train went on it maybe it was sagging or
something yeah maybe then he was just
like oh [ __ ] hey right that's not right
well yeah it's obviously all right
but yeah so obviously they have like um
you know all the rescue teams like come
and try to like get everybody out like I
said 20 of the bodies they never found
uh they did have a bunch of local
farmers and stuff and they kind of like
went down around the river and
everything they did actually get 60
bodies out of the river
um you know and uh I think like Queen
Elizabeth II was there at the time so
she kind of went on TV and talked about
how like thoughts and prayers and all
that [ __ ] or whatever
uh so they set up an inquiry to
investigate what had caused the problem
uh obviously because they wanted to
figure it out so to prevent it from
happening again
and what they determined was that uh
there's a type of mudslide that is
called I guess it's called a Lahar or a
lahar
I've never actually heard that term
before and I'm not sure if I'm uh
pronouncing that correctly but I guess
it's like a kind of mudslide it's a
particular kind
what ended up happening was that there'd
been a Mudslide because I guess like a
dam had burst or leaked or something
like farther upriver
and there'd been a Mudslide and it
washed away one of the bridge supports
and not too long before the train came
by so when the train came onto the
bridge like it couldn't support the
weight anymore obviously and it
collapsed and most of the train like
fell off so uh basically what I mean
this did have a silver lining because
the New Zealand Railways Department
um they actually installed a you know
mudslide warning system like after this
so that you'd be warned in advance and
you could stop the train before you went
on the bridge and uh actually this ended
up
um you know really like saving their
bacon in 2007 because almost the exact
same thing happened as in 1953 a big ass
mudslide came through and like pull but
this time they had the early warning
system and the train was uh stopped like
before the bridge collapsed and everyone
was fine so you know so like I said at
least some good came out of it even
though 151 people died which is pretty
[ __ ] up uh yeah so this is still the
most deadly rail accident in the history
of New Zealand so there's that and it
happened on Christmas Eve
here's another really cheerful story and
I'm sure this I'm gonna pronounce this
really wrong too this happened in South
Korea in Seoul South Korea the Diane got
Hotel fire 1971.
and I'm probably not going to say that
word again so we're just gonna call him
the hotel JK it's
d-a-e-y-e-o-n-g-g-a-k okay I've seen it
spelled a couple different ways but that
was the most common way I've ever seen
it he's like he lived in Korea for a
while he's like even I don't know what
the [ __ ] that is no yeah it's like I'm
sure I was I'm sure I was like way way
far off yeah uh but yeah this happened
in 1971.
and uh this building this hotel was a
skyscraper and this happened on
Christmas Day 1971 164 people killed 63
were injured uh deadliest Hotel fire in
history
so this hotel was 22 stories
a luxury hotel which had been finished
in 1969. it had
222 rooms now on Christmas day of 1971
there were 187 guests in the hotel and
about 130 workers like they think about
that many
um of the registered guests about 47 of
them were foreigners so we're not
Koreans but the rest of them were
Koreans
now interestingly uh this was 1971 and
this had just been finished in 1969. now
the way the building was designed
this uh has been uh you pointed to as
one of the things that caused you know
it didn't cause the fire at first but it
caused like a lot of people to die in it
because uh the hotel had two internal
stairwells now the internal stairwells
were there uh in case the elevators
failed but they didn't have any fire
exits and they didn't have any
staircases on the outside like that you
or you know no access to the outside
um and also the hotel didn't have
fireproof doors
so what ended up happening was that when
the fire started the stairwells filled
up with smoke
and it kind of like acted as a chimney
so it spread the fire quicker to like
the upper floors of the building that's
what ended up happening like like I said
the building didn't have any external
emergency staircases or anything like
that the walls between the rooms uh were
not fire resistant uh which made again
the fire spread much quicker uh and the
tower also didn't have any battery
operated exit lights which meant that
once the fire got really bad like people
had a hard time getting out because they
the Halls were dark and they couldn't
see where they were going so that was
like pretty shitty too
so they think that the fire was actually
caused when a propane gas tank exploded
uh they've been using it in the hotel's
coffee shop unplug as cooking fuel uh
the coffee shop was on the second floor
so this thing blew up it didn't
um the explosion itself didn't cause
that much damage but it did start a fire
and again the fire spread really quickly
because of the layout of the hotel the
fire ended up burning for 10 hours now
as I said a lot of people couldn't find
their way out because there weren't any
battery powered lights so when the power
went out they were kind of [ __ ]
because it was just all smoke and they
couldn't see anything
uh the fire department did come but the
ladders only reached the eighth floor
which meant that everybody from the
ninth floor to the 22nd floor was [ __ ]
um so only eight people were ultimately
reported as being rescued from out the
window and if you've seen if you do a
Google search on this there's one very
famous photograph that actually won some
kind of I don't think it won a Pulitzer
but it won like some kind of
photographic award for this year
um of a guy jumping out the window like
on a mattress like out of the like and
he's just like flying through there like
on a mattress and I don't think that
dude made it
um but yeah so it's like a very famous
uh photo
from this choice because people were
jumping out the windows because they
were burning to death you know what I
mean uh so they actually got 12
helicopters including some from uh you
U.S military bases nearby uh they
actually were gonna try and rescue some
people from the roof like using aerial
slings another thing was that the hotel
I could like hotels nowadays or any kind
of tall building nowadays they usually
have like landing pads like for
helicopters and [ __ ] like that on the
roof this didn't have that
um so there wasn't really anywhere for
the helicopters to land so they were
just trying to like kind of pick people
off the roof like with the slings and
stuff like that and I think a few people
did fall to their deaths while they were
trying to trying to get them up get them
off of the roof which is yeah uh so yeah
uh 38 people that they know of died
jumping out the windows not they're
burning again yeah and and again like I
said very famous photograph of a guy
like clinging to a mattress like flying
out the window which is like a really
disturbing photograph uh like I said if
you Google this hotel fire that's one of
the first things that comes up that
picture because it's very famous do they
have any video or film
um there's oh I don't know I saw the I
saw the still photographs yeah but um
but yeah it's pretty [ __ ] up and yeah
like I said they I think at least one
person maybe two like died when they
were trying to uh either they fell out
of the helicopter while they were trying
to get into the sling like into the
helicopter
um so like I said 16 people injured now
uh interestingly the hundred and the one
of the deaths that happened later on was
a guy that was the minister of the
Taiwanese Embassy in Seoul now he lived
alone in the hotel and he was trapped in
the building for 10 hours so he ended up
dying in the hospital of like smoke
inhalation like later on
so um so obviously this was really
[ __ ] up but at least
some people were held responsible for
this uh the authorities did actually
arrest eight people in connection with
the disaster uh including uh several
Hotel officials charged with
carelessness and improper Construction
and also they charge two former city
officials and a fire officer on charges
of negligence because they [ __ ] up and
like I said the construction of the
hotel contributed to not the fire but uh
you know the fire spreading so quickly
in the high death toll now the building
actually was remodeled after the fire I
think it's still there uh to this day
now on Wikipedia it says that there was
another fire there
um February 27th of 2010 but I looked
for an article and I couldn't find one
at least not in English
so I don't really know if that's true or
not because like on Wikipedia it said
that but then it said citation needed
you know what I mean so I don't know
where that information came from because
I couldn't really find it but like I
said I don't speak Korean so it could be
that it's you know something else
so the last thing I want to talk about
which somebody already mentioned and
this is just you know I'll go into this
kind of briefly because everyone kind of
knows about this because it wasn't
really that long ago
but this was another thing that happened
on [ __ ] Christmas
uh the Indian Ocean earthquake and
tsunami from 2004.
um yeah so yeah that's what I said I
left I remember a lot of this this is
like [ __ ] horrifying yeah so uh yeah
hit a whole bunch of countries in South
and Southeast Asia in December of 2004 I
believe it was Christmas day or the day
after Christmas I think it was
um so yeah December 26 2004. uh almost 8
A.M local time
and undersea earthquake with a magnitude
of 9.1
struck off the island of Sumatra
now over the next seven hours uh tsunami
which was triggered by the Quake
obviously just spread across the Indian
Ocean uh and really like they had really
high waves like all the way to East
Africa what are you doing back there
just laughing were you laughing at what
laughing about the Tsunami man brought
up some [ __ ] I'm gonna tell you about
stew okay stew in this tsunami but we'll
we'll uh we'll talk about it later well
I mean I only really just have one more
paragraph to talk about can you can you
hold on dude that that worked with nope
he can't hold it Stu was a dude that I
worked with him
he was funny as [ __ ] and his [ __ ]
work partner was this [ __ ]
skinny old [ __ ] black dude man I
forgot his name but they were always
[ __ ] with each other and [ __ ] one
time his [ __ ] work he said yeah Stu
came at me with that big old ass of his
it was a tsunami and I said what and he
says yeah he [ __ ] came at me was like
getting hit with a whole wave ass he was
just riding it like that he was saying
that Stu was [ __ ] him it was just you
know it was just [ __ ] and it just busted
up laughing and then from then on out
at Fleet mechanics [ __ ] Stew was
known as tsunami
it's tsunami the fleet is also a band of
a brand of suppositories Fleet yeah
Fleet he was known as students the human
wave of ass
this is what goes through my mind this
is why
I
laugh
and do [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] stories and I'm trying to
like you know keep some [ __ ] together
and like talk about I see him back there
going
I was thinking about stew like that and
I'm just like what the [ __ ] are you
doing back there it's like very
distracting because I'm looking at a
very Alpha place to work all these men
were [ __ ] [ __ ] with each other and
trying to
make other men gay it's just I don't
understand it it's just what's what
happens when you get these [ __ ]
[ __ ] together they're always
trying to flip a [ __ ] around
that I'm the man and you're the woman
so it's a constant wrestling match
mental wrestling match to make another
man into a woman
see we were into that transgender [ __ ]
long before you all were just that they
weren't willing the people were not
willing they were involved well that's
the whole difference yeah right yeah
yeah that's not the same thing at all
that was our version of it okay
that was our version of it okay time
whatever
how could those [ __ ] be men
around me it's just not gonna happen
it's just not gonna happen man that's
the that's the [ __ ] that's that's the
[ __ ] all right I ain't talking anymore
I'm getting in trouble James to say that
she's looking at me like I'm in trouble
shutting it down you're super super
drunk you are yeah I'm all right
you seem super drunk no
Zach said he was seven when the
earthquake happened holy [ __ ] Zach was
seven in 2007 in 2004. man [ __ ] man make
a [ __ ] feel old right
Zach was fresh out the [ __ ] that
though I mean well that's what I was
like I was telling you the other day
that I was like I was talking to [ __ ]
I was talking to Michael from a starry
night and he told me one time that he
was born in 1990. yeah and I was like
I was like I graduated from high school
in 1990.
you [ __ ] babies what is this all
about well I kind of feel like this that
happens to every generation it's like
you always
you always are shocked that you're as
old as you are and you're just like holy
[ __ ] like you know it happens to
everybody
it's it happens to everybody it's
happened to everybody like going back as
far as humans have existed man Mike's
Mike Barrett's in there [ __ ] he's
drunk too yeah he's dropped he's he's
drunker than you he's drunker than me
he's been saying he's been drunk for a
bad past hour
you're gonna be all right Mike
well yeah I mean you might be hungover
anymore watch out for the tsunami
sure
but anyway
um hard to get back to to the
seriousness of all these people dying
after me after that story yeah but all I
wanted to say about that was that this
[ __ ] tsunami man I remember this I
remember seeing like the [ __ ] from this
225
000 people
that they know of that's how many people
they estimated this [ __ ] thing killed
over 12 countries
Indonesia Sri Lanka India Thailand
that's just huge huge damage I remember
that
um but yeah just that's
I can't even that's a quarter of a
million [ __ ] people
that died in that I just tsunamis that
kind of [ __ ] that's like terrifying to
me because that's like it's you know
there's an earthquake you know I'm not
even expecting it you're just going to
match every regular [ __ ] day and then
all of a sudden this big [ __ ] wave
goes holy [ __ ] I don't like the ocean
you know what I mean so I don't want the
ocean coming at me
that's like very very disturbing hey man
just ask all these all these damn Maori
all these uh Island Boys we got
listening they know all about it their
whole culture is centered around the
fear of the ocean coming to swallow up
your Island well yeah all right well
that's a legit fear I'd be fearful I'd
be scared of that too you're gonna have
to put some Easter Island heads out
there to watch the others want to keep
it down yeah that's why they put that
[ __ ] there yeah he's like you guys keep
an eye on keep an eye [ __ ] water down
yeah holy [ __ ] yeah
I mean I you know and I grew up in
Daytona Beach which is right on the
coast like right on the Atlantic Ocean
and you know we had hurricanes and stuff
like that and I saw like some kind of
big waves but nothing like like
sometimes you'll see footage of the
tsunamis like because some people like
film it or it'll be on like um you know
like a building that'll have like some
security cameras or something like that
and it's just like I can't even imagine
it just looks like the [ __ ] end of
the world is just like a [ __ ] wall of
water coming and there's nothing you can
do nothing at all I've seen the videos
of it come it is yeah picking up all the
cars and moving everything and just
flushing everything away you just like
looking at it going wow you can't do
anything about it might as well kiss
your ass goodbye and there because
they're recording it from like the
window of a six-story building and you I
would be [ __ ] and I'm like man is this
gonna [ __ ] is this gonna wash away
the foundation of this building is this
building is gonna [ __ ] fall over
imagine that I know that's what I mean
it's like I couldn't even be like you
better I'm gonna be up on a roof I'm
gonna have the chopper come get me
and I mean the thing about it is that
you know it's like I said I grew up in
Florida so we got hurricanes but it's
like hurricanes at least you know that's
common like they warn you
so it's like well you know if it gets
real bad like we can leave like you have
a few days warning yeah you know what I
mean but I kind of feel like
earthquakes and tsunamis you don't get
no warning of that [ __ ] because the
earthquake just happens and then oh by
the way like as the earthquake wasn't
bad enough oh I'm Gonna Knock your [ __ ]
down and I'm gonna like also hit you
with a [ __ ] wave and it's just gonna
sweep your entire [ __ ] family like
out I actually think this there was some
warning for some of them because they
they know an earthquake happened and
then they give like a warning in certain
areas but how much warning is there
though like if it's a couple hours
that's what I mean it can't be that much
no
because there might be a big wave coming
some wild [ __ ] man that's how it is
nature hates us well actually nature
doesn't hate us nature is just
indifferent to us we're just like little
bugs crawling it's calm now compared to
what it used to be well it's way calm
you know a long time ago before there
was any life or maybe when life was
first being generated on the planet the
moon was so close to the Earth
that as it as the Earth rotated the
tides would go up like several miles so
the Earth was constantly being hit by a
huge mile tall
[ __ ] tidal wave just there was no
there was no crazy to think about yeah
there was no dry surface
that was and that went on for a long
time
and there was a bunch of tidal forces on
the planet that were causing the crust
to crack and there's a bunch of volcanic
activity it took a long time for the
moon to drift out it moves away I think
about an inch a year
and away from the but still got a plenty
of ways to go but uh it took a long time
for it to get further away from the
earth to where the tides weren't so high
that's when [ __ ] started to calm down
it has a very complicated very long
history of getting the [ __ ] kicked out
of the Earth
yeah that moon was
was something I think it was called
Thera before that or there were
before the planet had formed
there was just a ring here
and the ring started to coalesce into
two small planets they were on opposite
sides of each other with the sun in the
middle but one of them was moving
slightly
farther or faster than the other and
over time they caught up and collided
and [ __ ] planted went molten again
blew up and threw up threw up a bunch of
debris and that became the Moon
it's a wild [ __ ] man
yeah it's like crazy to think about yeah
it's crazy to think about but they I
think they said that those two [ __ ]
small planets that were in this orbit
here existed long enough for [ __ ]
life to have [ __ ] been formed on them
so there's no telling what was here
in the distant distant past you know
yeah it was a long [ __ ] time yeah
all kind of [ __ ] could have happened
it would have been alien planets
but uh yeah again I reiterate [ __ ] the
ocean every time that we watch because
we really like that show
I shouldn't be alive
and every time they do a show about hey
we were on a cruise ship or we were out
diving or something like that and like
our boat capsized every time I watch
that kind of [ __ ] I'm like yep [ __ ] the
ocean don't go out on the ocean for any
reason if you can absolutely avoid it
that's why I'm never gonna go on a
cruise or nothing like that because man
that [ __ ] sinks
you're kind of uh you're kind of hosed
not really anywhere you can go
I think I would rather be like trapped
in the [ __ ]
desert or the jungle then the [ __ ]
ocean
what do you think I don't know
you don't know I don't know what was the
question again
do you see what I have to deal with do
you see what I have to dance
I said if you had to be stranded
somewhere yeah
ocean Jungle Desert yeah where that uh
I'd rather be [ __ ] stranded in the
jungle yeah me too because there's food
there yeah
ocean would be my last pit yes food and
water there
the only problem I mean desert would
suck too but it's like I'd rather die of
thirst in the desert than get eaten by a
shark that's for sure I got jungle
training I'm ready for it there's the
worst thing about any kind of jungle
terrain is [ __ ] the bugs yeah I was
gonna say mosquitoes just eat you yeah
all right well you see that on Naked and
Afraid too but you know that's better
than [ __ ] dying a thirst out in the
ocean
or out in the [ __ ] or like I said
getting your leg bent off by a shark
that's not any fun either
but
I don't even I don't know I just I don't
like the
I've always been like really really
scared of
deep water because it's just like
there's so much down there and it's like
this black and it's like you can't see
anything and we don't know what the [ __ ]
is down there you're at and where you're
in the ocean you're actually flying yeah
essentially you're basically flying in
the atmosphere like over like the
mountains yeah which is a weird way of
thinking about it but that's what yeah
that's what it is right
you know because when the when the uh
you know water level is different like
the ocean sea levels are different like
some of that stuff used to be mountains
and [ __ ] and now it's like under the
flag of water and now you can like float
right over it which is kind of like the
kind of weird to think about God we're
to think about the fish see you as
flying because they're flying
flying through the water that's true
they're like What's this thing doing
they don't fly so good they're flopping
around yeah
one leg bit off by a shark huge [ __ ]
animals in there huge [ __ ] whales and
see I used to have nightmares like that
I used to have nightmares like that that
I was like in this black like thing like
that and then like this big thing would
go with like a big eye I think I had
that nightmare all the time because of
that ride they used to have at Disney
yeah like the 20 000 Leagues Under the
Sea like with the giant squid eye going
by yeah which I'm sure it's like not
scary I mean that ride's not there
anymore but like uh the ride probably
wasn't scary like adults but when I was
a kid I was like terrified by it but I
wanted to go on it all the time anyway
because I love scary [ __ ] but yeah
they're [ __ ] flying through the water
and get attacked by a bunch of [ __ ]
Humboldt squid man they Eat You Alive
yeah no thank you yeah no thank you like
you said it's I'd much rather like die
on land thanks there have been reports
of dudes fishing at night and Witnesses
said he was fishing and then something
[ __ ]
grabbed him and pulled him in
you know and for a while people didn't
believe it but it's exactly it was a
Humboldt squid can do that
again they reach out they're big [ __ ]
yeah they're pretty big
about four or five feet long but they've
got a tentacle some tentacles that can
reach out
another I think 10 feet or so and
they've got hooks and suction cups and
they can [ __ ] grab you on a boat on a
fishing boat and pull you in the water
and [ __ ] eat you and they're
intelligent they don't live long but
they're intelligent
yeah the weird thing about octopuses
octopus and squid is that for I mean
invertebrates they are like way scarier
intelligent and more intelligent than
they have any yeah need to be really
um you know
I don't know why uh Ben says they don't
usually come near the surface though
yeah well I don't know I think they do
on some occasions I guess it depends
where they do I guess they're hungry
enough they win it's usually at night
according to the programs that I've seen
they're also um cannibals they eat each
other they go into feeding frenzies
where they if one of them gets wounded
they all turn on it uh they're hungry
because they're growing so fast damn
Carl I thought it was your friend yeah
[ __ ] it I'm hungry they're growing real
fast they do odd [ __ ] but they know
their guys have been grabbed at the
surface
those things
it's always a nice way to go it's always
at night that's dark well I mean going
out of the I'm not even going out of the
ocean of the daytime let alone at night
[ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] tetsuo
said I was out smoking colder in a
witch's tit and a brass Brazier out
there yeah we're in Florida it's uh it's
right now it is 57 degrees Fahrenheit
and cloudy which is is cool for here for
this time of year Jeff yard says I'm on
a cruise ship right now actually oh [ __ ]
maybe I should watch something else just
kidding
I've never yeah I've never been on a
cruise my parents have been on but
it never
um
I like the idea of a cruise vacation
because everything is like right there
you know what I mean and like the place
you know the ship goes from place to
place so you don't have to travel from
place to place like I kind of like that
idea if it wasn't on the ocean it would
be a lot better yeah
that's all I'm saying
I think that's what that's what I don't
like about it yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] boats and
uh yeah pretty much [ __ ] boats um I mean
I like the idea of it and I understand
why people do it
but I also kind of feel like it's it's
and maybe this is changing nowadays but
I always kind of had the perception when
I was growing up that it was like an old
people thing
but I don't know maybe it's not maybe
maybe that's different but when I was a
kid it just seemed like that was some
like old people that's old you know
where that's what I mean we're not we're
old enough
maybe I should be but you know what I
mean I've said this before like what I
say when I talk about that's old people
[ __ ] I don't necessarily mean like old
as an age I mean old as an attitude like
because I've known like some 70 80 year
old people that were like cool as [ __ ]
they're really cooler than some 30 year
olds what's funny is that the old people
that caused us that existed that caused
us to come to these [ __ ] conclusions
of you know what I mean from you know
they're all dead now so they don't exist
anymore
so it's not quite the same situation I
mean but then again
[ __ ] boats
the [ __ ] boats yeah
pretty much pretty much yeah boats are
just a little bit better than Zeppelins
which were even [ __ ] worse I would
you'd never get me out of Zeppelin
either
I don't blame it they used to have them
damn [ __ ] luxury Zeppelins back like
in the 30s that were supposed to be just
beautiful you know and I think every one
of them [ __ ] [ __ ] caught
everybody they all died [ __ ] Zeppelin
and basically all the aviation groups
said you can't make Zeppelin safe they
don't they I mean it's a gigantic ball
of flammable gas I just don't know well
they came up with other gases that
weren't flammable that could work you
know like helium it's not flammable oh
but it didn't matter it gets too big and
it blows around in the wind and it's
they can't go very high so they're
always pretty much underneath the
weather I mean not always but and and
they're they're too vulnerable to
weather they wreck they crash
you get torn apart but I think most most
of them I think crashed on Landing
and it's blowing into the ground get
caught up in storms it's not worth it no
you know I'd rather [ __ ] yeah I'd
rather just take longer and take like a
Horseless Carriage or some [ __ ] people
forget how much lifting power those
things had though yeah much better than
an airplane you'd think that those
things would be weak oh it's just
floating around like a balloon they had
a [ __ ] tremendous lifting
capabilities they make a pretty good
military transport if you could protect
one but you can't there you can shoot it
down yeah I mean they're big it's not
like you can [ __ ] too big or nothing too
big too slow you can't armor it
Jason says the Jaws movie where the head
pops out the hole in the side of the
boat scared the [ __ ] out of me as a kid
yeah I mean I'm still terrified of
sharks to this day and I don't even go
in the ocean anymore and I was actually
when I was growing up
um I had a book that was all about the
ocean and even though it was terrifying
and like there were pictures of sharks
in there that were like really really
scary like close-ups of their face and
stuff
um I kept looking at it all the time
even though it like scared the crap out
of me Jeffy Hart said once you've been
to one uh Caribbean island you pretty
much been to all of them the ship is
nice with a mixture of Ages I'm with my
family so the drinking package helps a
lot I gotcha how much is that drinking
package can you like because I don't
know I've never been on it I know that
they have like they lay out the buffets
all the time because I know a lot of
people go because of that which I don't
blame you I would go for that [ __ ] too
where they just like lay out a bit yeah
you just like sit around and eat I kind
of feel like or play slot machines or
whatever the hell they do but even on
like a lot of the bigger boats they have
like nightclubs and [ __ ] too like they
had a bunch of nightclubs I'm not sure
and malls and all kind of stuff I'm not
sure you could get me out on that thing
not sure you give me all this
stuff see like I said I like the idea of
it but I don't like yeah I don't like
being on the ocean
bad [ __ ] could happen I don't know I'm a
little bit of a worry wart but I'm not
sure you could get us out there even if
this was like a if it was a Porn
Convention starring Tom and Jenny I
don't even still don't even think we'd
be able to you know they do a goth
Cruise right do they yeah [ __ ] they and
they have bands on there because I know
like VNV Nation used to play on there
even though they're technically not
really yeah a lot of Gods like them
people have gone on those things and
then just never been found again like
somebody threw them overboard
well see I kind of feel like that's I'm
sure it's nuts doesn't have but you know
my little True Crime mind all the time
I'm like ooh that's like the perfect
crime like you want to like bump off
your wife or something like that she
just like fell over but I don't know
where she went yeah and it's like you
know it's happened before you're gonna
be bobbing around for several days
before you die you could be dying to
thirst man [ __ ] that
Jeff here it said the drink package is
about 400 for 15 drinks a day for 10
days oh [ __ ] not bad actually yeah 15
drinks a day jeez could I even do that
well yeah yeah who am I kidding they're
probably pretty I probably could
every week
Ben says there are serial killers
working on those boats I don't doubt it
I don't know what does it work like Jeff
yards on the cruise
sand all this [ __ ] [ __ ] about all the
serial killers are like people pushing
each other over for it
well I mean you know
that's the first thing I think of when I
well okay the first thing I think of
when I think of a cruise ship is one
it's gonna sink and I'm gonna get eaten
by sharks second thing is ooh all you
can eat buffet third thing is Perfect
Crime that's where you that's where you
go if you want to push somebody off and
like make it look like an accident the
all-you-can-eat buffet deal I don't you
can get that at a casino though that's
true and I don't know if there's one and
a casino can't sink well Casino can't
sing technically I guess it could
because you could have like a week we
probably have an Indian Reservation
around here there's one uh there's some
the seminal reservation is over by Tampa
okay and there's a big ass Casino over
there yeah that's where you go I've
never been to it but I know some people
that have been usually there's got nice
hotels there and you can yeah it's like
a whole big thing and you don't have to
stay a week you can stay a couple days
yeah what the hell is it called it's my
it's it's either in Tampa or Lakeland or
it's between Lakeland and Tampa or
something like that Seminole reservation
it's like a big big casino and
everything a lot of a lot of the uh the
casinos have all you can all you can
drink as long as you're gambling you're
gonna get free drinks
yeah because they figured the drunker
you get oh yeah they're more gonna be
like ah whatever I'm losing all my money
I don't care
is it true to you that they don't put
clocks in there no no probably not so
you don't know how much time you're
spending probably not yeah I kind of
thought that was either I used to go to
the ones in Biloxi and Pass Christian
you know [ __ ] like like uh Harris you
used to go to that one you used to go to
[ __ ] think it was called Pirate Bay
you just go to that one that was good
used to win money there I wouldn't put
money on [ __ ] roulette
just [ __ ] making roulette bets on
[ __ ] black or red he used to do that
and I used to bet the two [ __ ] bets
on the outside and leave the three to
open and you get that [ __ ] 50 return
if you won that was a good if you were
patient you could win money on that
walked out of there [ __ ] 300 up on
that one time and it started with only
40 bucks
see the thing is once you get you're up
you go look man I'm way up when I came
in here you gotta leave you stay in
there you're gonna lose it all well yeah
that's good I think people get to like
like if I put all this on here then I'll
win like a whole bunch more and it's
like that's when they get I was thinking
about it you know what I'm gonna get
this over with I should take all this
and just bet that [ __ ] on red no I got a
pretty good chance
but I I didn't do it I knew that it
would but but the Temptation gets you
yeah you're like there's almost a 50
chance it's like a 48 or 49 chance that
I'll [ __ ] double my money if I just
put that [ __ ] on red
and it's quite a [ __ ] temptation
now if you start running big like that
you better [ __ ] hand out good tip to
your [ __ ] dealers because they
they make a lot of money that way you
know but
they are kind of helping you because
they're saying are you sure you want to
do that because they'll help you place a
bet you sure you want to do that they'll
tell you the [ __ ] odds and everything
if you ask them you have no the right
questions ask them so what are my odds
and they would just go not good I
wouldn't do it it's okay I'm not gonna
do it especially on blackjack
yeah at least at the casinos I was at
but if you're if you win money make sure
you tip your dealer
Ben says they pass laws here that all
the slot machines have to have the time
displayed interesting as far as I know
the slot machines are all rigged
I think they're rigged
well it's like I don't even know if it's
so much that but I think it's just kind
of like yeah
um you know obviously obviously
everything in there is geared toward
making the casino as much money as
possible so you're always at a
disadvantage I don't think you're at
random there's no they don't even make
they're never even make the claim that
they're random so they're they can't be
random
they're making jackpots hit on people
got them yeah yeah and stop and that's
why I wouldn't play that
dudes that really [ __ ] Gamble and
just just gamble don't do anything they
never they never play against the house
what they do is they go uh play [ __ ]
uh poker against other
yeah other batters all right and that
the house gets a cut of all the winnings
but you're not playing against the house
you're playing against the other players
that's really how you do it because like
I said if you're playing against the
house you're always at a disadvantage
but you're gonna lose basically long
enough you bet long enough you're gonna
lose the house is as it all
statistically rigged can you win yeah
you can but not for long yeah you have
to walk away you gotta know when to hold
them listen to Kenny Rogers yeah yeah
you gotta know you know what he was
talking about yeah exactly yeah I'm not
even talking about poker but
but no uh [ __ ] in those Mississippi
Casinos you had people pulling up in
winnebagos and camping out in the
parking lots and that's all they would
do is is they're playing poker yeah yeah
and they're not from there they're from
other states and they'll be in there for
a week playing poker
ain't that something yeah like it's a
job well yeah I mean well it is for some
people like they make enough money to
live on yeah doing it yeah they're
literally like if you're good enough at
it you can they're living in a mobile
home
out in the parking lot
and they're drinking for free
and eating for free a lot of times those
casinos will have like will they get
free buffets yeah sometimes if you're if
you're betting enough the table if
you're winning they'll give you a
[ __ ] perks to a free free visit to
the buffet and they got crab legs and
everything back in those days that was
they probably still like that
so they're eating there living in that
damn Casino living good as long as
they're betting and the dudes that
really knew their [ __ ] were playing
poker and they would so I knew one of
them
and uh he he was [ __ ] at a regular at
the restaurant I was working at at the
time
and uh he was
he said that the the trick was
is to not not sit down at a table that
had good players so they've had good you
knew who the good players were
you wanted to [ __ ] sit down at a
table where it was just tourists and you
take all their money basically yeah that
seems the wise decision and then they
would just hang back and just wait for a
weak table to form and then you'd go
over there and they'd [ __ ] take all
their money and then they go back and
wait again and they just drink and watch
the tables and they just try to find a
weakness so they were [ __ ] hyenas
basically but that's the game that's the
game well like I said if that's how
they're making their money if I was [ __ ]
hot at poker that's probably what I'd be
doing too because that sounds kind of
fun yeah
and then like
the guys that were in the scene that
were the good poker players they all
knew each other and then sometimes they
get on there and play as a team against
other people and take their money they
would do that too but mostly they like
to play by themselves
against
saps people that didn't really know how
to play right
Jason said a woman fell off a cruise
ship last week in South Australia they
did fight they found her dead body she
yeah that's well like I said I said it
happens
murder Hornet said Vegas is free drinks
but the waitress won't come around in
like every hour so it was useless trying
to get drunk
I think my my sister's going to Vegas in
uh February I don't have to like ask her
if she's gonna go and hang out at the
casinos on the Mississippi Gulf Coast
drinks came pretty regularly but they
were weak
yeah that's what yeah that's what uh
that's what that's what they were saying
earlier that's I mean that's probably
why if they're gonna give them to you
free they're not going to give you good
[ __ ] they're not gonna like you know but
if you're there for six or seven hours
you're gonna get you're gonna get pretty
loaded but you but you've been betting
for a long time
which that's that makes a difference to
them
you've been in there risking your money
losing money
that's what they want
you're there to lose money
yeah and so I never really got into
gambling it's like well I never really
had any money to spare like that I could
lose because I always needed it for [ __ ]
but it's like
I was okay at black at roulette because
roulette and roulette's could be
considered kind of one of the middle
games
it's kind of a loser game you know I
mean a lot of the real experience guys
wouldn't do that one because the odds
are kind of not good enough
um but for somebody that's not a real
skilled Gambler it's easy yeah so you
know
um Blackjack is a little bit tougher
um
although the dealer can tell you whether
what they would do well you want to
double down you want to hit you know so
you can but the thing is I never like to
[ __ ] play on a play using a dealer to
help you and you lose money quickly on
that one and
I just didn't you just didn't really
like that one that that much some people
love a crap table and there's a bunch of
different ways to bet on craps you can
bet on that [ __ ] a [ __ ] million
different ways and some dudes are real
those are games of luck partial skill
but mostly games of luck and chance and
I'm good with luck and chance I don't
know why maybe my psychic abilities
[ __ ] make those [ __ ] dice land a
certain way I don't know I can feel it
when it's coming
I could feel it when [ __ ] was coming on
the roulette table
I said no I'm not gonna bet for a while
and then I jump back in and then start
winning some money and going this isn't
right man I'm winning too much I got to
get out of here and then I jump off the
table a little bit until I felt more
comfortable then I jumped back in
some people are saying well now you're
adding another element of chats though
of when you're in and when you're out I
said man don't question it it's instinct
kiddo
because if you're in all the time it'll
eventually just drain you dry yeah
because the statistics design yeah right
foreign about to visit my grandma at the
blackjack table yeah also I'm two out of
15 drinks in so I gotta get going yeah
you need to get caught up you gotta you
got 13 more drinks before you can send
us some of them winnings
murder Hornet said yeah no closing down
in Vegas 24 hours going yeah I just kind
of feel like there's people going in the
[ __ ] casino is like oh and girls out
there [ __ ] trying to turn tricks
you're in a casino
pretty much yeah they're just trying to
be slick about it though well like I
said everybody hey everybody everybody
gotta [ __ ] make a living yeah yeah I
don't begrudge anybody making money all
these [ __ ] pretty girls are gonna
start [ __ ] coming around you
you walk away they're gonna follow you
that's what that's that's I've actually
never been to Vegas yeah
my uh my sister's been several times and
my brother has been several times and
they actually really really like it
there but I don't know like to me it
always I've never been so I don't know
maybe I'm maybe I'm misinterpreting but
it it always just seemed kind of like I
don't know kind of seedy but not not in
a fun way
what's that Vegas yeah [ __ ] Vegas
actually I like the Mississippi Gulf
Coast better because it was smaller and
it was [ __ ] newer and uh it wasn't as
like I said didn't have a CD element to
it there didn't seem to be CD you know
it kind of had a little bit of that but
it wasn't it wasn't that bad you know I
liked it
you about ready to shut it down Jim I
reckon yeah we've been on like two and
yeah
two hours and 45 minutes yeah okay it's
ready all right so we're gonna jump off
here and
go ahead go ahead and like the video
people yeah everybody like yeah share
and subscribe share subscribe well I'm
sure everybody subscribe well you better
be subscribed God damn it uh but yeah so
hopefully you guys enjoyed the show this
evening Friday night we're gonna be
doing our side track show but so it'll
be another Christmas show although
probably we'll talk about a bunch of
random [ __ ] like we usually do uh that
probably doesn't have anything to do
with Christmas but you know maybe uh
maybe you'll have some eggnog on that
show maybe we'll get Christmas themed
drinks for that show okay we should
probably do that because we haven't done
that in a while and I feel like it's a
holiday so maybe we should do that
all right so uh anyway so we'll see you
guys again
Friday night thanks for stopping by
thanks for super chats and we'll see you
again on Friday good night
foreign